what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the
pregame before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in guys that is
the most important metric that YouTube
uses to push out these streams King how
many likes to open up the chat today um
1,500 okay guys 1,500 likes and we will
open up the chat to everybody guys like
is free so hit that like button also
guys if you have a question comment or
concern that you want to ask the panel
Um send a Super Chat King what number
Super Chat 25 so over $25 super chats we
will read so if you have something you
want to say super chat it also guys make
sure you sign up for our membership tier
the first tier gets you to be a part of
the live chat second tier Discord and
behind the scenes flogs if you guys want
to see me freestyle rap second tier
third tier you get to connect with me on
social media and a fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month
also guys go follow my Instagram just
pearly things one and make sure you go
subscribe to the audacity Network page
we're going to be launching some shows
on the network page so make sure you go
subscribe so today we have a lovely
panel why don't we go around everyone
say your name age relationship status
and a fun fact about yourself starting
here and actually add your profession
too today so starting here go around
okay um my name's Deja I'm 25 I'm single
um I work in film and television
production and I'm from
Atlanta um my name is Rebecca um I'm 30
years old I am um starting up events so
event
management um fun fact about me my son's
birthday is Christmas day oh
well my name is Rachel I'm 40 years old
fun fact about me is some people know
already is I only eat meat and I've been
doing that for four and a half years um
yeah that's
that hi I'm Natasha Boon and I am a
singer and I also have a flower company
I'm 32 years old and I'm
single hi I'm shiron I'm 31 years old
and I'm working in
marketing fun fact oh fun fact about me
is I was born in South Africa and raised
cool guess that's me I'm Sterling 36
single I'm a sex coach for men and a fun
fact I just bought some Farmland oh oh
nice can anyone to hear milk a
cow no all right
disqualified can you of course I can can
you he's got
L can you can you kill a cow and butcher
it easy oh
easy is that is that like a normal thing
for you no I'm just I'm just a capable
person so of course I can do
that okay go ahead hi I'm Christine I'm
23 years old I am a YouTuber here at the
audacity Network and in a relationship
fun
fact my favorite band is Pink
Floyd go ahead all my name is Q um 34
years old currently single um own a
couple of companies own qsl construction
Naz nail Lounge um got ownership in
performance Hub sports car garage and
fun fact about me is I'm humble humble
enough
anyway go ahead uh my name is Jerome
darche I'm a singer songwriter actor a
whole all round entrepreneur fashion
designer and the fun fact about me is I
am the
fun
wow that's awesome all
right okay um so today um our topic
today is when do women expire yes my
question is do women have an expiration
date and if so when is it she's shocked
she's like oh
no
so so so um we're gonna we're gonna
we're going to start with a very nice
video um which is amazing and awesome
let's pull it up
[Music]
was oh
okay okay I guess it's so um the reason
okay I guess I'll I'll guess I'll tell
you how I came up with this awesome
topic today so um
basically I I tweeted a couple of months
ago and I had a very profound and
amazing tweet and I said 25-year-old
women are hotter than 35-year-old women
now to me I just thought this was Bas oh
she's shocked she's like oh
no I to me I just thought this was basic
water is wet the sky is blue younger
women tend to be more attractive than
old older women and it got me to
thinking you know is there a date or is
there an age where women are over where
they're basically considered just for
fun for men where they're too old to
start a family with and they would not
consider them longterm I also wondered
if there were any exceptions to this
like if she was really hot like she's 47
but she's an eight she looks like JLo is
there an exception I I don't know I
thought we would ask the panel today so
um it also was inspired during this
video that I saw which was women
documenting their experience really um
with dating after divorce let's pull it
up I can't hear it
King know that your best years are ahead
of you much
fun you can it you see yeah so there we
go so my question is is there an age
that women expire at starting here and
then go around um I would say no
especially like this day and age we have
Tik Tok and everything and we see like
all these older women flaunting you know
their appearances and everything I would
say um women don't expired no okay go
ahead um I know we've kind of had this
conversation before when I've been on
the show before and you basically told
me after 25 you're done no I didn't say
after you're 25 you're done 30 it's like
you're basically not worth it no no no I
said I said if I said no no this is what
I said I said if I was a guy you
wouldn't want to dat somebody yeah over
25 because most of the time they're so
set in their ways it's like you can't
the feminism is like in the ears and
stuff there's exceptions though but
mostly no yeah go ahead do women expires
wait what do you think though don't I
didn't ask you what I thought
I how did you dodge this question what
do you think I I have my opinions go
ahead personally I think 30 30 okay
women are expired you're you're 30
though yeah
I'm wait wait wait wait put yourself at
the
game you single as well
yeah there's there's some humility in
this chick you know go ahead when are
women expired I do think it's individual
I'm older than some of the people here
today okay and um yeah I do think it's
individual I think if someone looks
after the themselves they look after
their appearance and they're a good
person then you know there's no
expiration date no I do think there's
there is but you can push it a bit
further okay so when when is the
expiration date for someone that takes
care of themselves so I don't think I've
expired at the age of 40 so that that's
all I can say okay well I didn't ask
about you I asked
about I asked when do women expire let's
say give me a girl that takes care of
herself and a girl that doesn't
okay so a girl that doesn't take care of
herself well is she ever in the game if
she's not taking care of herself is she
well I mean haven't you heard that
Patrice O'Neal thing that where it's
like a ugly 18-year-old is still hotter
than a hot 30-year-old no yeah well no I
don't
agree I don't well older women typically
don't no
offense what that say no because think
about it it's like at 40 at 40 or 40
a guy can't get a kid out of you the
18-year-old can lose weight no I think
you can have a child at 40 yeah but it's
not it's not
probable I I think it's doable if you've
looked after yourself it's not likely
you're on the Carnival diet you're good
okay okay so what age does a woman that
takes care of herself
expire um maybe she needs to be settled
down by 45 at the most okay 45 go ahead
um I don't think that we that women have
an exploration date just purely because
different needs are met at different
ages so I might have been really for
someone when I was younger but really
even more for them when I'm older once
I've experienced a few more so I am over
30 but I don't think I'm expired okay
they didn't ask about you but when do
women me I said no no so they never
expire so at at 55 she is equally as
wanted on the market as she was at 25
she could be wanted but it depends on
who wants her this is what I'm saying so
it's like depends on what so men of what
age so an older man might appreciate the
more older women he might have had
enough of younger I'll I'll tell you
what they surveyed men between the ages
of like 20 and 80 and they all found 22y
olds roughly the most attractive What
What In women yeah 22 yeah I I can I can
see why are they youthful I remember 22
yeah yeah but it's like if we if we
don't expire why do women get BOTOX to
look younger I don't
know I don't know they want to be more
youthful reme reminiscing right but it's
like we almost know that we do because
we all try to look young yeah it's true
okay so so we do expire what age I don't
think we expire I don't think we expired
just because we want to be youthful just
cuz we want to be youthful doesn't mean
that women expire women do not expire
okay women are okay go ahead what about
you expiration dates well um it depends
on what what exactly what she said off
the back of that who again men but
what's the purpose so milk can go off
but I'm sure once it's off you can use
it for something else well yeah that's
when they become that's when like side
chicks for
sure you can get 50 old side chicks no I
know I agree with you they they they
tend to tend to accept that when they're
older no they
do I mean again I think it depends on
what it is that you want out of the
person I would say for a long-term
relationship or marriage when you're
women longterm if you pass middled age
what is longterm longterm these days can
be two years longterm can be okay so but
when a man is looking for a woman to
settle down with is there an age where
women typically are spired just based on
their age bially yes again after
yourself or not i' hope that a woman
that's looks after themselves
biologically hopefully the clock can
push to 40 plus okay 40 40 plus okay so
50 is she
expired biologically perhaps okay thank
you I'm actually going to do the men's
second so I'm going to go Christine and
then I'm going to ask the
guys I mean we're talking about the
dating Market here so we're talking
about the general rule of there are
exceptions I mean someone like Rachel
you don't look 40 right truth is most
40y olds don't look like you so if we're
talking the majority I would
say 27 28 2728
expired okay um let's go to the men when
do women expire for you for a longterm
prospects make this loud and clear women
do expire okay you get to about 30 years
old and there there's no point in
getting married there's no point in
having kids and stuff like or imagine
having a kid at 40 years old and then
being 50 with a 10-year-old yeah that's
kind of crazy so for you over 30 you're
kind of Dum over 30 there's no hope in a
long-term relationship and planning
marriage and all that kind of stuff I'll
say over 30 it's just so I have a
question what if she's 30 but she looks
like JLo at 30 would you make an
exception for me me personally it's a
smash and grab Smash and D you you're
still it doesn't matter what she looks
like 30 okay what about you um I just
think it's like the terminology
expiration for me is a bit harsh um so I
don't really want to talk on it on that
sense of using that terminology but what
I will say is um I don't think there's
an expiration date it is what it is your
own individuality well but I'm asking
for you for regarding women yeah so when
you you're dating I don't think if I'm
dating somebody and their head screwed
on and we're both getting it together
then I'm not looking at her in that
aspect of an expiration do you want kids
and like a family oh I've got kids okay
you've got kids I'm single but I've got
kids but I would love to I'm a family
man you understand so I could I'm 36 I
could see someone that's 40 or or so
forth I'm not going to say she's expired
my mindset so 40 but what about 50 I
don't want to say the word expiration
maybe maybe we've got to a point of
we've got to a point of it's it's coming
to your time okay and in a respectful
way but yeah okay so roughly for you 50
4 45 what about 45 that's cool for me 45
and under okay he doesn't
discriminate Sterling what about you to
the same age that I think women will
start to pay a lot more attention to
themselves and put a lot more effort and
work in to being beautiful is the same
age where I cut it off and that's 24 24
that's very and what what's the differ
like what makes you pick
24 typically less
indoctrination uh like less
feminism more feminine because they've
got less years in the workforce being in
like their masculine energy kind of
having that drilled into them all the
time yeah the primary reason is there's
a lot more runway for making a family
like there's a lot more years on the
clock I want a lot of kids I want a big
family that you can really only crank
out like one a year she needs some time
off right maybe if she's got twins in
the family maybe twins run in the family
cool we can crack out two everyone loves
to buy one get one
free if that that's coming out if she's
guaranteeing twins we can push that time
frame up a little bit the womb needs the
rest yeah like you know I want a lot of
kids so we going to need some Runway and
like the younger a woman has kids the
older she can actually keep having kids
until the danger becomes when a woman
has her her first kid in like the later
years of her life life that's when you
get things like geriatric pregnancy you
have to have C-sections otherwise
there's serious dangers there like my
mother she had she had me she's the
exception of the rule she had me at like
37 she was worried I was going to have
Down syndrome because that's one of the
complications of a gener geriatric
pregnancy like more more likely and
stuff like that so there's risk for them
okay so I want to go through a woman's
life here so under
25 30 30 to 35 35 Plus okay so I want to
say is there ever an age where a woman
should
consider you know like take marriage off
the table like marriage is you know
marriage is no longer for you I don't
the average age of first marriage is 31
in the UK to say so at what age would it
be easier if a woman took marriage off
the table I don't think women should
take marriage off the table never never
okay that's women men might have a
different answer to that but marriage
I'm gonna I'm gonna I want some hands
here um all right so if a woman is 50
should she take marriage off the table
raise your hand you guys who Wants to
Marry a 50y old really 50 okay all right
35 should she take marriage off the
table 35 okay then all right so
basically the women think marriage is on
the table forever yes what why would a
man marry a woman that's over the age of
35 for what purpose cuz you got an A
terminal
uness
Mar what what value does a guy get from
a woman over the age of 35 companionship
if you was with that individual for a
substantial amount of time that's okay
if you met somebody randomly it's a bit
iffy buy no no she's you met her 35 Plus
that's well 35 there's no problem with
that at all okay 50 OD
do you know what for me yeah this is a
bit mad CU if you meet someone that's 50
yeah and you like them and you have a
connection with them and companionship
why would you not want to marry well
what's the purpose of
marriage family kids disagree agree
you're not going to get none of that and
that's it but what if both partitions
don't want that they don't want kids get
enough headache I would say what's the
point of marriage zero point I think
marriage is different for 50y olds than
it would be for 30 yeah it's complet I
think it's completely different their
mindset of marriage is completely
different different yeah well I I would
say that at that point you know just
being a long-term relationship what's
the point of
marriage that's why I say when does it
go off the table because it benefits the
women and the women's going to get
something you say never you say never
it's never off the table you guys when
did you when should Sterling when do you
think like under 25 to 30 under 25 is
what is the kind of woman I would ask to
marry me above that again like like like
I said before I'm I don't see the runway
there like the time there's not enough
time so you wouldn't marri anybody over
25 I'm going to go with 25 as well I'd
only go with 30 if I've been for a while
just let me with it you get it okay so
Al the and you say under 45 yeah 50 is
pushing it but like around the 40 mark
cool we're good all right so I'm
wait 50 should be gone before I'm
gone
who who here thinks women should never
take marriage off the
table wow we love selling
drink yeah let them be happy let them go
get their little marriage day no you
know your chance if you after you the
age of 35 is of getting a ring ladies
who wants to know it's not 5% higher
than that oh
okay it's 15% over the age of 35 they
get a ring uhhuh they get married and
that's that's the previous generation so
I would guess if if you're not married
after 35 in this generation where
marriage is less common it's probably
going to go down going to say this
generation probably never get married I
think we're just setting ourselves up
for failure at this point at the end of
the day if we say we're never taking
marriage off the table you're ultimately
setting yourself up to fail cuz I think
realistically if you're not actually you
know married or engaged by 25 chances
are it's probably never going to happen
and if you tell yourself one day it's
going to happen one day it's going to
happen you're constantly living in Hope
and expectation so then when it doesn't
happen and you're on your deathbed and
you're not married you're going to be
thinking oh I've not I've not found love
but it's like if you put it out your
mind if you just say like by the time
I'm 25 if I'm not married I'm going to
put it out of my mind if it happens
great but then if it doesn't at least
then you're not going to be upset that
you didn't get it well we've been sold
we've been sold a lie that women deserve
a husband and that all women are going
to get them when the truth of the matter
is most women most women will not have a
happy ending like most if you look at
the stats half of women aren't going to
have kids or a husband out of the half
that do have kids um if they get married
so maybe um let's say the other half
gets married half will fail so you have
one in Four Women that'll stay married
if that and I'd argue it's even lower
because you have to count account for
women that had kids and didn't get
married there's a big thing here as well
like a big part of why I set that age
range so low is because the higher up
that ladder you go the more entitlement
women tend to have M like if you look at
that video we watched before there was
at least one of those women in that clip
she was like why don't men open doors
anymore that's just one little example
you'll see lots of Clips like that on
Tik Tok of women who are you know in
their 30s Not Just In that clip but
there there's this the the level of
entitlement seems to stack up the longer
they have waited for someone to pop the
question do you think men shouldn't open
doors I you think they absolutely should
open doors 100% no I was going to say so
you feel like women are feel more
entitled after 2025 yeah because they
haven't got what they were promised like
like pear just said they there's this
level of they've been promised they've
been sold this dream their whole life
since they were a young girl like you're
a princess you're going to find your
prince charming this is going to happen
and it hasn't happened yet hasn't
happened yet hasn't happened yet that
expectation is building up and up and up
and that builds that entitlement along
with it but if we raising young girls to
believe that they deserve Prince
charmings are we raising our sons to be
Prince
charmings no we not so how do you expect
to expect something if it's not even
been brought forward wait are you can
you explain that more are we raising our
sons to be Prince Charm if you he said
you know the entitlement is almost
installed in you from a young girl
you're princess you deserve this so when
you don't get it past 25 the entitlement
is already a part of you so touch
whatever age but so is this supposed
Prince Charming that we've raised her if
we have a son are we raising him to be
the perfect gentleman that we expect for
someone's daughter because if someone's
son right but who is he being a
gentleman for no but that's what I'm
that's my whole point if we raising her
to have
expectations maybe somebody has a son
are you raising your son to be a prince
charming as a young woman as a wife or a
mother well I would say I would say
women don't reward Prince charmings they
don't they don't women do not reward
good behavior Noe in general I I would
say if women did reward good behavior
and chivalry then you would see more of
it men will do anything to get sex but
if we don't reward it how can we be mad
when they don't do
it so who's entitled women oh women
because not because they want a reward
for being having decency and manners and
courtesy and women women no because they
because because they're not trai we're
not traditional exactly that's the point
so it's like we're asking for
traditional a 25y old was probably a 24
yearold was born mhm not that long ago
24 years ago we in a society where this
is not a part of their Norm what isn't a
part of the norm to be traditional right
so you are raised you she's being raised
to be a part of a masculine world that
is what the norm is now right so a more
traditional woman is probably going to
be older but unfortunately she's been
cut off because she's expired no I would
say more traditional women um are going
to be married is traditional right cuz
traditional women get married before the
age of 25 typically perhaps yeah so so I
would say no the older women that are
still single like they have a term for
it it's called leftover in
China they they call women over and I
think it's over the age of 30 or maybe
even 27 28 and they just called them
leftover cuz like if the products
amazing wouldn't someone have bought
[Music]
it notice there a in in the language are
using as well it's like it's it's all
always what does she deserve it's not
what has she
earned it's that's that's what I'm
saying about the entitlement right
because women AR yeah exactly I'm I'm
just Ling right it's not we're not
teaching young women like oh you need to
earn your prince childing you need to
earn a good man good husband you should
just be given you should you are
entitled to it and it should just come
to you one day magically from the sky
without you actually like sitting down
and saying you know what I I here's
here's when I want to get married by I
want to get and I'm going to put it at a
reasonable age because I'm I I know that
it's a competition because everything's
competition in life right and so I'm
going to take my dating decisions a lot
more
seriously right than than most women
tend to do at a younger age okay so wait
would you question go ahead I'm just
wondering what a woman at 24 has done to
earn a good man because at that point in
like you probably haven't had a secure
career young you haven't stacked up that
expectation don't I don't care about a
career don't care I make I make more
than enough for so you you aren't
looking for necessarily a partner you're
more so looking for a wife a wife she
she a part it it's complimentary right I
don't need another me yeah I don't need
someone to replicate what I'm doing and
not as good as I do it either like I
make more than enough money for both of
us I I want a woman who's going to be
feminine Who Wants To Be A Mother who's
who's going to provide that nurturing
energy right and yeah someone someone
look after my kids someone to look after
me like in in the aspect that she can
and it's my job to keep us all alive
yeah and be the man yeah we've got
different roles complimentary and you
asked what value a girl at 24 um brings
I mean typically they're thinner
typically they're more pure typically
they're more youthful typically they
have less baggage so I I would say like
those are the things that men select for
okay it just it just sounds like we're
comparing tools or pieces not women with
with you know but do we Sorry are we
looking at also what your foundation is
so a lot of people maybe some religious
or something like that those are things
that are installed in young boys and
young girls to Value certain things and
whether it's Christianity or Islam like
you hold yourself in a certain Manner
and then becomes what is valued to you
so if you don't have these things at
home I'm not saying only religion does
it because you don't have to be under a
certain religion to do it but if you're
fundamental foundations with your
parents or whether you're however you're
raising a child if that's not installed
in them from a young age as they're
growing why would they know to Value it
how would they know to to Value yourself
as a woman would so it all comes about
to what your that entitlement and your
teaching so if a guy was raised by drug
dealers and then he chooses to deal
drugs should he not go to jail for sure
you should still go to jail right that's
the point even if you were raised by bad
parents and you don't know how to to be
a wife and you make certain decisions
like it doesn't alleviate you from the
consequences of those
decisions so um so I'm curious now I
kind of wanted to go into this all right
I wanted to I had some ideas what could
if you found a woman that was over the
age that you typically date for for this
for the
guys she's 32 let's just say except for
you
but she has that makes up for it what
does she have yeah could cuz there's
something that a girl could do if she's
over a certain age to make up for the
fact that she's
old company homecooked food house clean
um there when I get home not going out
partying um respect for my parents just
so you would you would if she was really
respectful you would date a 32-year-old
if she had had all that stuff I need to
come home to peace about someone
complaining about something or someone
you know winging about her friends or
gossiping I don't need all of that I
mean I just need to know that I'm
comfortable when I get
home as long as she's bringing me
comfort and peace yeah that's right but
then I would normally go for someone a
lot younger I probably wouldn't even pay
attention to it at first okay so
now okay what about you um basically I
was was with someone that was 35 yeah
for 3 years so she's like 38 now nearly
40 yeah and she's got four kids and like
I stayed with her because of the
companionship and we was good together
she could cook she she was doing
everything right so like I wouldn't
really this is why I'm stressing the
fact of this expiry date thing because
at her age and the age she's at now
obviously if we did stay together then
it would have been good but for me it's
just a case factor of she did did
everything that was okay for me mhm so
yeah I didn't drop her out because of
the age okay Sterling what about you
she's she's 25 in a
month out the door not a chance her
birthday is next week she's almost
25 throw out the rest of the trash no
uh okay 20 20 can she milk a cow can she
all right she's she's 20 she's 29 but
can milk a cow that's 4 n it's to to
many years bring that bring that number
down a bit so 20 all right 28 but can
milk a cow 25 and can milk
cow and know had a garden okay we might
go if she has a garden that's knows had
a garden yeah it's a good green thumb
right know knows how to make gross
veggies knows how to cook I mean that a
lot of these things I'm I'm already
going to select for things like even in
the 24y old it's not just the fact that
she's 24
like there's other things that go into
that it's not just like the age I'm
looking for right there's like obviously
like Purity there's like political
leanings towards my kind of political
leanings or or at least like you know uh
maybe conspirac if she okay this I I'll
add numbers I'll add age here if she's
like a conspiracy theorist she gets at
least 27 27 at least 27 she's like a
full-blown conspiracy theorist all right
this this girl's kind of crazy in a good
way like like I I I could get a kid in
her real quick yeah yeah yeah like she's
like all right we ain't got time the
world's ending yes all right that's my
girl you
know okay um what what else do you
select for like what give me give me
your list of standards in a girl um cool
so we went over age ideally like not
college educated okay ideally like in
fact if she if she went to like a really
big college that would be a massive red
flag okay so she's main she's 22 but she
went to a mainstream College like if she
went to like in in America for example
if she went to like a big like a big
college with like fraternities and
sororities and [__] that's a giant red
flag okay huge red flag that that woman
hased a lot is she off is she off the
table completely oh okay basically yeah
so she says I went to unless unless like
if I can I mean look in a girl's
Instagram will give a lot of this stuff
away yeah like I can tell if she was in
like a sority party I can tell if she
was like going up and down bman street
or whatever like they'll tell on
themselves on their Instagram that's a
big one does she have an Instagram if
she do does have Instagram we'll push
that we'll push that that age right up
no Instagram could you no social media
at all 27 no problem what about okay no
social media yeah 30
yeah got one this ain't this ain't a
negotiation all right this is a
dictatorship we ain't negotiating no I'm
just kid I want to know how many years
it gets here what about 30 but she's a
virgin that's pretty hard that's where
we're oh what if she's what if she's a
magical
unicorn happen I
mean we're talking in fantasy L someone
said if she went to ASU she's done for
sure Arizona State definitely yes
definitely y okay so what else what
about okay go ahead let's say let's say
she's she likes the She Wants To Be A
Mother okay she wants to be a mother and
family that's giant green flag like cuz
she's looking for the same thing I'm
looking for a family right uh she likes
to cook right doesn't have to be the
greatest cook but she's willing to learn
to cook the things I like excellent uh
random acts of kindness so like
something is simple something is simple
is like I'm sitting down and working at
my desk and she comes up and just gives
me a nice shoulder massage out of the
blue yeah that is a giant like winner
that'll add that'll add a
year not to years
you got one more year Runway All Right
these kind of things uh not two though
we don't want to get carried away yeah
we uh what is prefers like country life
over City Life okay or like quiet Town
small town life over City Life okay not
a giant parier not a big heavy drinker
doesn't do drugs doesn't do weed that's
a big red flag for me the girl does weed
nope I don't care how young she is nope
out 20 but weed
out no no you can't negotiate with me on
this I don't negotiate with
terrorist um all right 20
22 but but goes to the
club twice a
month I would have to find some of her
friends or the people she's hung out
with and get like the
dirt get some like Insider int H are
women snitches
100% 100 everyone's
noing this is they stitch on thems of
course they're going to stitch on the
girlfriend um okay I wanted to ask about
XS okay women have XS men have XS so I
want to talk about what is the last time
you've broken up with someone over
something like what was the ick or like
stopped going on dates with someone I'm
curious from the women tell me the last
like ick you got with someone you were
seeing um I would say like he has some
sassy gestures
like just picking stuff up like the way
you drinking out of a glass we're
sitting at the movies and you got to
have like is it the pinky is it like the
te with the pinky it's the it's holding
like why are you eating a Popsicle as a
grown man like I don't
know I saw Tik Tok and it's like um men
have to eat certain stuff like break it
off like the banana like you need to be
breaking the banana off and toss it in
your mouth like you don't need to be
doing all these sassy gestures so yeah
that's definitely it for me cuz why you
so
loose wow it's true you sound pickier
than
me oh my gosh he could stop with the The
Sassy gesture she can't
unage I'm just K okay go ahead um mine
has been for communication I can't deal
with somebody that doesn't communicate
well with me okay what do that what do
that yeah that's communication as in we
can we could have a conversation right
but if you're still walking away and
saying well you're you're still in the
wrong that wasn't the communication
wasn't really there cuz you've listened
to what I've said but you're talking
about talking you're talking about
arguments specifically communication
barrier needs to be there why don't why
don't you just not argue yeah because it
depends on what the argument is about it
may not have wanted to be an argument it
may have just been something that I've
brought up and now me out I may be the
bad one because I've
nagged nagging or may it is nagging or
hear me out we could just not we could
just not bring it up yeah we could but
then that's why I would rather walk away
from it either way either way that's
where the relationship ends cuz if I
can't if I actually cannot open my mouth
and say yeah if I feel like I'm being
but why do you have to express him can't
you like cuz what what I'm hearing it it
just I could be wrong I don't know you
right but from what you're saying it
sounds like codependency where the other
person needs to adhere to all of your
emotional needs so what I would say is
why can't you let it build up a bit but
at least then you keep the peace in the
home and then maybe you can call your
mom or you can call your friend and go
he did this really annoying thing but
it's a little Annoying Thing yeah no I
don't believe that relationship should
be involved in family members and
friends I'm sorry I'm not going to call
my friend and be like oh he did
this a little thing so something big
yeah unless it say something big what am
I even talking about anyway right but
you said you you mentioned the word yeah
so it it gets classed as nagging cuz it
may be something that I've brought up
and swept under the carpet and I've Let
It Go could be like 6 months later now
and I've decided you know what I want
this conversation
again what's can I can I have can I have
an example of like what what you're
thinking of a situation what happened
what Happ it's not AIC situation no no
there's there's something in your head I
see
you know what is I hear it a lot as well
from women it's just that it's just the
communication it's for me it's
communication you but you see okay but
you see how broad this is to a guy CU
there's guys watching right
communication and that's all women says
communication they communicate with me
yes sit list just tell me listen listen
but you're the if you're the okay so but
isn't that sort of narcissism I need to
be told yes all the time well no not not
yes all the time but I mean at least
just try and take in whatever I'm may be
expressing at the time if it feels like
it's gone over your heads but what if
what you're saying is stupid then tell
me I'm being stupid I would that the
whole a lot of from what I'm hearing
right it sounds I had a friend who go
went through a kind of a situation
similar to this in the way his M was
communicating this to me it's it kind of
sounds like you need you just needed him
to tell you everything's going to be
okay I just wanted to know if if what
I'm saying you actually feel that it is
stupid or you agree with what I'm saying
there needs to be some sort of
understanding if there if we haven't
come down to a decision of yeah you're
being over like over the top how was you
coming across sometimes it's not what
you say it's how you say it's how you
deliver it yeah and sometimes a lot of
women are very Aggy and it's just a bit
of we don't approach it correctly that
is keep stepping that is another thing
it is how you um approach it and how you
um yeah open up the
conversation calling you stupid though
but I I I have listen I'm very
understanding I know how to communicate
I'm very grown was stupid how would you
react to that I'd want you to explain
why the [__] I'm being
stupid it do no but you know what it
does it ends up coming down to that the
cycle of the argument how women get into
arguments with guys and the whole that
it it sounds like you wanted an argument
because you wanted his attention yeah
you wanted his
attention up you you get an argument
going he he fires back you get five
minutes of his attention but he's fired
up and passionate with you no it could
be something simple like every day I asy
babes can you make sure that the the
dishes that you put in the sink you wash
it if I've now dealt with that for a
whole year and after a year I've been
like not babes I've dealt with you not
washing the dishes that I've asked you
every single day to make sure you wash
and you come up with some silly response
of well put them in the yeah don't you
just accept that he's not going to wash
the dishes in the sink and just leave it
just like it's about
acceptance just using I'm just using um
an example but B get me a dis I'm just
thinking buy me a
dishwasher credit card pleas I'm just
thinking what else is the chick there
for isn't that your job no that was just
an
example
example I couldn't think of another
example I just thought this but I mean
like you have to remember I'm a mother
at the end of the day so I speak to my
child all day long I after don't do this
don't do that I don't don't want to have
to deal with a man and say babes don't
do you know after that that's it I have
to keep reminding you not to do
something I'm I'm so but but so do
exactly live exactly how I want other
but that's the point like you're not
supposed to try to control someone
someone yeah yeah I know but only off
the F they try to do that also I was
going to
say I I was also I was also going to say
if if that's the way you're even going
to put it ain't no daughter of Eve is
going to tell me I told you to wash the
plates like in whose
house no but
the plates no but the point is even if
it's an example that is the way you gave
the example so that's more than likely
the way how you how you approach it is
that how you approach though on a normal
day that's how she's probably going to
approach it because if that's not how
she was going to approach you she would
have given the example in of the yeah
fact I'm scared of you ladies let get
into our scar stop it let be scared of
me I mean I'm very I I like to get my
point across do do you get angered very
quick by men I would say in a
relationship I would say a few years ago
1,000% but now you control your emotions
I've calmed down a lot yeah cuz it's
very much a lot learning to understand
the person that you're with
understanding my wrongs all right I feel
like um correct me if I'm wrong so I
feel like your preference of
communication comes from like instead of
just sweeping on the rug and you know
leaving you because I realize something
about you let let me make sure and
confirm this is who you are and I'm not
saying that's the right mindset because
if somebody is not washing the dishes
for a year then they probably not going
to ever wash the dishes so you need to
accept that but some people would rather
communicate fight through it and maybe
if you get some understanding you can
change somebody's mind not necessarily
change their habits but change their
mind get some clarity on this is how you
think this is how you move this is type
of person you are rather than just
sweeping under the rug a year later now
I'm pissed off I'm just going to leave
you because you've done XYZ we've had a
conversation and you understand I'm not
going to accept this now I'mma leave you
yeah can I ask you if you does was the
dishes what's your response damn go
Hoover now go in Hoover you're not
hoovering not ho now well no
I mean during during these conversations
there there's always going to be a
reason like if I'm stating that there's
a problem yeah going to say this is the
problem if you can't give me a reason as
to um why you you you do what you do or
you don't um acknowledge that it's
something that irritates me that is a
form of lack of communication it just
needs I just need I need the man to be
understanding I hear what you're saying
right but I think I think the truth is I
think it's all about mindset really I
don't think most men think I I I don't
even think people should think like that
of like why do you do something why do
you do something like at the end of the
day if I go into the middle of London
and start beheading people does it
matter why I did it you did you done it
I feel I think I don't think it I don't
think it matters one of these people I
need the whole story I need like from
like the start all the way to the end
people Myer searing for for meaning does
that not mean that you're lacking
meaning somewhere because you're trying
to find it in something else outside
yourself I wouldn't say I'm lacking mean
and no I'll just say I just like I I I
need okay I wouldn't I don't let me try
and phrase this right I I just like
somebody who can communicate I've had
relationships where you know what the
man can tell me you know you're being a
[__]
and no wait but wait didn't you say
didn't you say earlier your first
question is well why yeah that's that's
exhausting to a guy that means he has to
like go back but that's to me no but
that's that's the the point is the point
is it's like you're looking for an
argument when you do that like to a
man's point of view but we just never
hear this because we don't really hear
the men's point of view but that whole
thing like that's exhausting it is
exhausting and as why I'd rather just
done it cuz if you can't communicate
with me then that's that's just that's
my I anyway it's for me it's
understanding communication if you can't
do that with me okay sounds when I when
I hear when I hear chicks talk about
communication it always and I'm telling
you just how it sounds to me um do
exactly as I want and I need to tell you
every time I'm irritated otherwise
there's going to be problems not really
because then I wouldn't end up being
with some of the people that I have been
with CU I've I would say I've
compromised with allowing certain things
like what I'm not willing to piss okay
you you said it you said it that's the
only reason say certain things but yeah
I would I would say I'm I'm willing to
compromise with a man okay do you do you
feel like men have compromised on you
yeah 1000% okay so it's like a mutual
compromise oh yeah okay could say that
okay okay what about you I X so X would
be Bad Manners the way someone holds
themselves um how they treat others
eating with their mouth open would be a
massive that would be a no how about
eating vegan
food thean
up um I haven't done a lot of dating or
anything I've only ever had long term
relationships really so I don't have a
major experience in my relationships I
don't think arguing is a good thing I
don't think um so you know in my last
relationship I didn't argue or anything
like that because you know you're there
to actually complement each other you're
there to make each other's life easier
um Advance you you want to actually you
know your man advancing advances your
life too you guys didn't argue you guys
didn't argue at all no Until the End
okay Until the End I was like I was like
I was like you guys you should you
should get married then this sounds like
a great relationship yeah we were
together for a long time oh okay yeah
but no um to the end because of
situations and things that happened so
okay what about you ick um ick in
general yeah just the last ick the last
time you were maybe you went on a date
or two or you and you thought I can
never see this guy again ever and this
is
re feel like so bad said it though but
the last ick that I had was um someone
asked me out for a coffee and he's like
come and meet me for a coffee so there I
was happy to go meet him for a coffee
and he turned up with his friend so I
was
like who does that at the age we're at
now how old how old imag how old was he
he's he's 30 he's 30 this his mentality
imagine so I was like shocked and I
thought thought no this can't be
real where's where's the
camera like it's a prank honestly I did
I think so I thought some of my friends
were setting me up and then I thought no
he's he's not
joking so the lady in Starbuck am I
allow to say that the lady knows me
there so she's like coconut mocka and
I'm
like so I look behind me and um he's
then gone and ordered his drink and his
M's drink but I've got my app ready to
pay and I'm like no way am I paying for
him and his mates
coffee I swear to God I paid and left I
swear I swear paid and left I don't
blame you I paid and left because so
awward yeah listen it's my local I
couldn't do that to myself it's my local
it was too shameful plus my points were
nearly collected for my free new
one that was a big ick for me and some
of my friends were like that's really
shallow what is it shallow or not it's
not at all cuz I felt so violated and
disrespected in that instance of him
just showing up of his friend in the
first place yeah there's not one
masculine trait like it wasn't it wasn't
like a business meeting or something no
no no no imagine no he brought him for
coffee too no and I have a company so if
it was a company setting I no I know I
paid I I act so so embarrassed I swear I
was I was embarrassed I was embarrassed
she just wanted to exit yeah had to take
the lead I left that weird I am
ultimately quite bossy though like I was
going to lead on to if it was a meeting
a business meeting fair enough I'm used
to sitting on boards with all people and
buying the coffee that's all right I
don't mind that but it was asking me out
to get to know me that's why I was shot
it even bought a friend did he even did
he mention it why the guy was
there security
guard over the situation no no he did to
be fair they're not he wasn't from the
area right to be fair and he was like my
friends um I was like why have you why
have you bought your mate and he's like
oh he was just you know in the area and
I was like oh it was getting worse how
did you meet him so we was talking for
like I'd say about a year or two on on
Instagram we met yeah we so we met
through other friends and yeah it
continued through Instagram so I would
say instram two years leading up to this
day exactly can you imag you will never
get that time back exactly time is your
currency boy to be fair in in all
fairness it was an invested time on my
part but I'm just saying in general for
like about two years we had been in
communication and hadn't met up in
person so when it come to that time I
was so upset like I couldn't believe but
that was an Nick yeah me off the ball B
me off
I get it though I get it I get it we
yeah that was mine what about you last
I uh the inability to
lead yeah what is like can I have an
example of that not B the
Cofe um I like I okay it's about what I
like obviously this is about me so I
like a man a masculine man that's not
intim ated by somebody else or the next
person next to me if you're into me I
want to feel your aura your presence
around me cuz I'm clearly I'm into you
and I'm all about you and I don't need
you to be all about me like drooling on
me
but I feel your presence energy energy
and if I don't feel that it's just such
a and you don't have to do the grandest
gestures but the lead like the in a
restaurant not being able to open the
menu yes you're getting to know me but
what would be nice and what would be
good is after you've gotten to know me I
would like you to place my order I think
that's what my man should be able to do
so the inability to do that is a big egg
okay so you if he doesn't place your
order then I want a traditional man so
if you're not traditional you're an egg
okay do you think you're traditional
100% okay um what makes you traditional
probably no no let me take that back um
wait wait
ready let me
[Laughter]
78% what what makes you traditional I
have a lot of Traditional Values I was
born and raised in a different country
so my morals Compass is a little bit
more different and um than people that
were born and raised more West okay so
I'm just going to say that like what I'd
like to be a homem maker I absolutely
love
family the traditional I'm saying
traditional old older way older way um
because a traditional when you go and
saying the word tradition it means
something from before right so it's an
older way today's Traditions are
different yeah because of the way the
world is okay we kind so therefore if I
could in the ideal world when things are
all Rosy and it goes my way I have like
my five or six kids and my husband and
yeah okay but I'm still not hearing what
makes you traditional me um I I'm I'm
peace what does that mean I I am peace
to my partner right but what is like
what do you do specifically that
communicate effectively I cook I clean I
I I run our home effectively I do my
part okay so and you were like raised to
do that your mom taught you that um my
family taught me to do that my mother my
grandmothers my the men in my family um
yeah okay but I do my part but they did
their part too they they what was the
men in my family did their part too they
they provided yeah my grand so you're
saying I saw good examples of what men
do and still do and have done so my
grandfather's my actual father um and
yeah my moral compass I think is we all
again 78% not 100% we all do things that
precise number
again I live I live yes we live in 202
what three so wait how how old are you
again that1 okay so usually traditional
Women Marry young MH typically so what
made you not cuz I'm only asking cuz if
a guy I think I said I was single in the
beginning did I okay um I I I thought
you said you weren't married I didn't
say that but I'm not married to to in
the Western World now not oh okay but
you're you got like a ring or something
yeah I've got plenty of rings no I I me
like you did it in the church or
something I don't know we don't do that
okay are you married are you married yes
I have a partner are you married we are
yeah I mean to us we are together yes
are you married okay so so no no to what
the Weston signing legal documents that
count no no I don't have religious
islamically married yes okay so okay so
you are
yeah we yeah we we go together real bad
real bad Okay Okay cool so your parents
raised you to do that one of the one of
my purposes yes okay what about you last
ick uh I think I already said it weed
weed's was that did you go on a date you
went on a date with someone and she was
I I I rocked up at her house to pick her
up and like the door opened and it was
just weed Central weed Central Amsterdam
it was Amsterdam I'm like
all right dinner cool see you next time
like I'll I'll still take her I'll still
be a gentleman take her out for dinner
and get to know her a little bit but it
was like that that was just in the back
of my head the whole be that much of a
big ick if you still took her out well I
didn't see her
again I was also hungry and wanted to
eat I'm I'm on my
way you know I book the table for two I
don't want to sit like a
[__] can I ask you why why the weed
is an
ick I've just been around enough women
when I was living in California and it
just irritates the hell out of me like
women who are high are the most annoying
women on the planet really cannot stand
it okay cannot stand it yeah and it's
and like they're always they're always
messy they apartment is always a
complete pig sty like everything just
stinks of weed all the time they think
they're
spiritual not the think spiritual
that was funny that's
funny the big the biggest problem with
with a chick who smokes weed is like
they they get so dependent
on if you if you date a girl who's like
smokes weed cuz I did in the past I've
dat a girl for like maybe maybe it
lasted like two weeks she was like a big
weed smoker she couldn't go anywhere
without a joint or a bong like she if
she was without it for like half a day
she'll start bugging out man they go
like they become hyper irritable like
super paranoid and Annoying It's just
like calm down woman like not dear God
you have a you have a problem you're
addicted to this thing and you don't
even admit it yeah yeah they'll never
admit that they're they're hooked on it
they'll never admit it doed so is it
codependency someone that has a
codependency marijuana or anything so
what if it's yeah what if it's another
form of Vice I mean any other form I'm
not if she does any hardcore drug no I
mean like people if they don't have
coffee they might start doing exactly
what you maybe I mean I've never I've
never met someone who sits there in
chain chain drink the ca I want more I
want more more more more caffeine more
caffeine what about you biggest
I uh biggest ick I think is like
political views and like values like if
they're a liberal just don't even come
near me at all I missed that one that's
a good one
like oh I'm I'm sick boosted and I I
believe everything the
government get away I I I have one I'm a
feminist like a guy that says he's guy
says to me he's a feminist I will throw
up in my
mou got I've been I've been on I've been
on a date like that he told me that I'm
like you were talking to the
wrong wait was that recently was that in
the last few years no this was this was
a couple years ago okay so he wasn't
aware no no no no but I was like this is
the wrong that's that's a big red flag
imagine not only are you thick as [__]
right but you're just not even a man at
that point they're very feminine they're
very feminine preach they have a just
they nor it's
like it's like they're just sort of
robots like they're not even people at
that point NPCs like you're just an NPC
men that wore masks I don't I don't mess
around with people like that that's an
I'm liking this panel more more but yeah
that and an an inability to to see into
the future and that just gives me an ick
in people in general like if if you
can't see what you want and be able to
put things into place to execute it um
that just tells me that you're you you
have an inability to think critically
and strategically about things which I
think is a really masculine trait to be
able to do that um and I think you were
talking about the whole a woman when
she's older having to be in her
masculine energy more well that's
because then women have to think about
right I have no one to depend on who's
going to do this for me so I have to use
my brain myself which means I need to
think about where I'm going to get to
and how I'm going to get there I think
it's really attractive when you don't
have to think around a man and you just
know they're going to get you somewhere
um but I I do think women do need to
have a a level of of being able
to operate because again you know if you
have someone who can't operate well then
you end up with a liberal
so can't King do not start on me about
my scrambled eggs oh and ability to make
scrambled
eggs think scrambled eggs are an
omelette basically chopped
up I get it though I get it I get it
scrambled eggs supposed to be fluffy
yeah thank you they are they're the
best okay uh what about you
ick uh ick probably someone just loud
mouth
overweight um a dictator someone that's
like oh I want to sit there like door
don't like the way that looks or
complains like the waiter or something
like that someone just doesn't make the
whole night peaceful have you been on a
date recently where a girl did something
and made you not want to talk to her
again see I'm more of a a longterm my
relationship has been long term but in
between those gaps
um see me as well I'm a bad responder as
well cuz what you're saying about
responses and that I'm the kind of guy
that will message you and they won't
message you back like good couple hours
and it's not that I'm doing it on
purpose so I'm busy do you know what I
mean and for someone to keep
consistently messaging me consistently
messaging me and that's kind of a Nick
for me as well okay I kind of like to be
oh so if if they're messaging you too
much yeah and just don't look after
themselves they need to look after
themselves as well cuz I'm I wake up in
the morning I'm in the gym by like but
she needs you she's like so excited yeah
he's like he's like nope
again I'm a busy
person I don't know like I sometimes I
find that that kind of neediness you're
talking about sometimes actually I find
that attractive yeah to AE to a degree
me she's going to be obsessed with
me which is a good thing I want but I
agree with you the same same time I
ain't sitting there all day texting with
you to it you know what I mean like I've
given a girl Freedom before and it
backfired on yeah so I do agree with the
you know paying attention to me and
stuff but there's a level to it you
can't overdo it cuz I'm not going to
respond back to you and then you're not
going to like that yeah you can't expect
it in return you can't expect it to be
like equal amounts of attention giving
back and forth it's good that you're
obsessed with me but I understand I'm
busy like you're going to get the
occasional High I love you that's it
like and you have to you have to learn
to be okay with that cuz otherwise this
ain't going to work yeah see that with
my ex-girlfriend [__] when she told
me that she loved me that was enough for
me for the rest of the day I didn't need
to hear it over and over and over and
over again do you know what I mean so if
I say to her I'm busy she understands
I'm busy for the whole day I'm not busy
just for the next 20 minutes or so it's
an understanding between you both I love
that a lot of people don't understand
that cuz they're not at peace with them
what you doing now what you doing now
Angry you on your way who you
with what's her name her
name what's her name no joke okay can I
tell a funny story P I had I had a
French ex who did basically exactly that
I went out I went out play poker with
the guys right Friday night just me and
the boys phone died while I was there I
get I get home plug the plug the phone
in I just start hearing bing bing coming
through coming through it did that for
about 2 minutes straight it it wasn't
relenting I'm like what on
Earth I look at it as about 40 text
messages about 20 Miss calls and about
seven voicemails oh and it starts off
I'm like drewing them in sequential
order and it starts off with hey babe
what are you up to I'm free later on let
me know when you're
finished and then it I what are you
doing you can feel the text is
get who is she who is she was the last
text and then it went and the voice
notes were like just her crying into the
phone like again and again and again and
again I'm like much who your broke up
with it right after that that's what
you're going to do with 24y old
right that that girl was older than
24 I've learned my lesson no no the
biggest the biggest misconception is
somehow older women are more mature no
no no no no I'm easy to deal with no no
no no no no I I think 100% of the women
I've kicked out of here and that have
not listened to B rules have been over
the age of 25 100% like I can't even
think of oh no there was one sorry
thought I won
but was one there I forgot about
her but but by and large no cuz when you
think about it when women like date the
more people women date the the higher
their standards get and when we admit
this on social media you see you'll see
girls say oh I accepted all this
treatment in the past I'll never accept
this treatment again it's it's basically
making the men of the future pay for the
mistakes of the
past you disagree
um I feel like just in general it seems
like we're like taking every
responsibility of the relationship off
of the man like the woman has the woman
has to be understanding she has to
conform to whatever you want to have
going on in your household like I think
maybe my idea of a relationship is just
a little bit different like I don't know
it kind of seems like you want a younger
woman that you can like mold or like
kind of make a certain type of way or
that will kind of like accept anything
and I don't know if every woman is going
to be that but it's somebody for
everybody so you think that's someone
for everybody um somebody's going to
like something about somebody like no
it's not true there's a lot of very
lonely socially awkward men maybe they
just haven't been they haven't been
everywhere in the world they probably
haven't you know that's how people find
their second win that's why people do
get Remar how do people get around the
world by being rich which means that
they're the top 10 20% of people which
most people aren't going to get to I
mean I've traveled I live in another
country I'm not rich
so I mean I'm not saying that I'm not
saying that you have to be all around
the world but I do think you know if you
put forth that effort if that's what you
want if that's what you're seeking if
you're going to put every energy yeah
explore and meet people and date people
and find people like you're it's going
to be and it might not be your choice
but there might be somebody who is into
you and wants what you have to offer
yeah but it's not the people that women
want so so the difference between men
and women is men already conform to what
women want so men know they have to be
tall they they typically have to be in
good shape they typically have to have a
good job and make money they typically
have to be charismatic to get women to
even talk to them the difference is
women don't know what men want because
they'll still sleep with us and give us
attention so women are not forced to
conform to what men want because we'll
get the attention anyways and there's
evidence that suggests that 50% of women
are never going to have kids or get
married and then you take the women that
do get married 50% of them will divorce
and that's by 2030 so it's not even that
far away so like if we take this room
for example how many girls are there in
this room 2 4 6 7 at least let's let's
make it nicer than it is at least three
of us will never get married and never
have kids and that's a fact yeah and
that might be true I'm not saying just
because there is somebody for everybody
you're going to find that person you
might not have the opportunity like I
could go out in the street and get hit
by a car and I can die tomorrow and I
didn't have my opportunity to meet my
soulmate but just because I might not be
everybody in this room's cup of te that
that might not be my ratio that might
not be my room to be in and you know I
actually I actually agree there's always
there's always a guy that will date a
woman there's a woman who will accept
the man for no but that's that's the
difference women will not accept the men
there are and that's why there's so many
divorces so I'll tell you what percent
so they surveyed 5,000 men and they
asked what percent of men have had more
than one sexual partner in the past
year what percent of men said that they
did guess um I would say 80% 10% m
so women it's it's basically 100% of
women are sleeping with 20% of men and
it's the same when you look at dating
apps women swipe no on men 80% of the
time so and they only swipe right
5% so that that's the problem it's not
that the women can't get anybody but
it's once we've hit a certain level we
can't go down and women and women admit
this right they go they go around and
they say raise your standards you're a
queen you're amazing and then like don't
accept the treatment that you accepted
before but the problem
is you there's not enough men that women
want to go around M well I think that
might have something to do with the way
our culture and mindset around
relationships have definitely changed
like you guys are saying you are wanting
a traditional relationship well nobody
is moving in a traditional way these
days so that's why you're not going to
find people you have older men looking
for someone half their age because you
know they're not their in with the women
who have these mindsets that they've
gathered from pop culture or whatever
that's going on today so you know if we
have this imbalance of people who are
agreeing on what they want out of a
relationship or what they actually can
provide in that relationship because I
think a lot of people also aren't
realistic with themselves um then of
course you're going to have some type of
imbalance in the amount of people that
want to be married and people that will
get married no but the reality is women
today don't even understand what
traditionalism is because because when
women say they want to be traditional
they always have this idea of the man
pays for everything the man earns so
much money that he can ker for the
family but the reality is most people
that were traditional back in the day
weren't even living that kind of Life
the women were literally working
alongside their husbands and still gave
them the respect of being the man of the
house they weren't living any soft life
most people were poor for most of
humanity so every family you see that
have come through time is only a few of
them that actually lived a soft life so
women today all want to live like the
queens of the past I agree and so do the
men that's why you have something called
The Sassy man apocalypse like men are
literally running around bragging about
that's dat of wom I actually disagree
because all throughout history only 40%
of men have ever reproduced so the
reality is throughout history men have
never really been at the table like
women think the only reason why you
think men have been is because it's the
men you see and those are the men that
actually
desirable what percent of men do you
even think can finesse dates um I think
like I said it's somebody for everybody
like you literally have stuff like
people that come out of prison and they
find women on Facebook and now a woman
is taking care of them paying all their
bills like women women do love wom women
you've been watching
FBI Facebook Facebook she she's actually
she's actually off the
up that's real life she so you're
actually you're not you're not wrong
about you're not you're not wrong about
criminals like um violent criminals are
more likely to reproduce but that's
because women are attracted to men that
can protect them and there's some
biology where women you know think that
if a guy kills someone else some reason
that they can kill for her too it's not
and women hate to admit this women
absolutely hate to admit that that's
what we find attractive but there is a
reason that every single girl loves
watching horror films and documentaries
about serial killers that's true thank
you true what percent what percent of
men do you think women find attractive
what percent of men
um probably like 25 30% you're close 20%
but I also feel like that's an issue as
well like we think we have so many
choices and we don't have everybody on
the hinge it's not your choice like
you're not going to meet everybody in
the world so you can't just base it off
of who you're attracted to like there's
so many more things that go into a
relationship woman say that you're right
but the problem is that's what women
select for in their 20s that's the
number one thing women select for in
their 20s is looks and money goes higher
in their
30s and so when women have the most
options they're selecting for looks and
they're only dating and sleeping with
the top 20% of men well that's what I
and that's why that's why the that's why
the women will say men are trash men are
the problem because they're all sleeping
with 20% of men where 80% of men aren't
really getting play at all no I agree
that means 80% of men on the hunt for
these women oh I agree you don't gotas
to get that 80% you need to settle down
with the scrub with the
bag denel is not coming like he's not
coming and that's why people think that
women expire so early is because you're
looking for somebody who has this
certain image that you seen on Instagram
you see on social media where you're
sleeping on you know every other aspect
that is the the important things in a
relationship looks will fade because if
you ask me if women have an expiration
date so do men like just because you can
keep going
like but but the difference is men men
don't expire the same way women do I
would argue if men have an expiration
date it's maybe 55 50 but if you look on
dating apps what if you want to the most
swiped right age on um I think it's like
Plenty of Fish or something for women
guess what it is 18 18 and guess what it
is for
men5 probably 60 because it's not for
not not that no no no it but it's what
we're attracted to don't okay are you
attracted to a guy that has a good
career and he's hardworking okay then
what does that come with age that's true
this is true but yeah and are you are
you are you attracted to a guy that's
wiser than you that knows more about the
world than you yeah in general yeah but
men don't care about that they don't
care about what you do for work they
don't care about how wise you are about
the world like they they kind men are
kind of attracted to girls that are
naive and and that comes with youth so
we're just not attracted to the same
things this is true and I feel like I'd
say teachable instead of naive okay yeah
potato pot well moldable moldable has
like a manipulative flavor to it but
like if I can teach her about the
reality of the world and she's going to
she's going to like learn it conform way
better than if she's on my like if I can
get her on my game plan we're all going
to win right if she's like combating me
and fighting it cuz you got all this
other programming in her head already
yeah we're going to be fighting each
other the whole way that's it and then
she's like he you going to for you so
many other people have tried to teach
her stuff so by times she comes around
to me all I got to teach you you're
going to tell me everything but then
that also comes down to obviously we're
not talking about age but when you're
having a partner one of my things is um
I say to my friends before we got here
do you have the desire to want to
unlearn some of your BS Behavior do you
have that desire as a friend as a family
member as a whatever because some things
may not be Serv you the way you think it
does so for example the young lady over
there said um communication effective
communication the way she receives the
way she delivers he might decide that
you know what I'm not saying he needs to
conform to um her to throwing her toys
at the car to want an argument whatever
but he understands that maybe that is
means that she just wants a bit of
attention so I'm not even going to feed
into that I'm want to go and um give her
a hug whatever it is that he knows MH
gets her to a place of comfort where she
feels safe whatever it is that so that
again you're understanding her
communication that is the worst advice
ever what what to unn bad behavior no
like when you said um if if she's doing
all of that then he just I'm not saying
he needs to give a hug I'm just saying
whatever works for her no but whatever
works for her is not what he should do
or whatevers because because what
happens is is is just like the child
analogy when a child throw tantrum and
then you suit
their you literally tell them that
whenever they want something they can
get it by doing that and so you're
literally teaching her bad behaviors
right so then back to my original point
was do we have the willingness to
unlearn so perhaps it's the open
conversation that needs to happen at a
later stage or there and then if he
wants to have that conversation can he
effectively communicate that can they
both take it in and understand cuz you
can listen and hear something but you
may not understand it mhm so you can
just say yes
okay did you hear me yeah I heard you
did you understand me but then if I
drill that into you then maybe that's
what she meant it's a nag no you know so
again unlearning bad behavior or
unlearning bad habits that were
installed programmed Society outside
social media whatever it is that's one
of the things we have to be willing to
unlearn things that don't serve you or
serve the purpose of wherever the
relationship is MH I'll just say though
I'll just say though there are some
things that men can actually tolerate
women but the worst thing is is that
particular behavior of wanting to nag or
argue it's even in the Bible it's better
for a man to live on the corner of his
roof than to live in a house with a
corome wife if that's in the Bible then
like every religion on Earth has
actually have something to say about
things like this so it goes to tell you
that there are just some things that
women should actually work on and this
is the problem a lot of women don't want
to work on some issues and they just
want to like we said they they feel
entitled and they feel like they deserve
this but the reality is you can only get
what you earn and what you work for so I
don't
know um King could you pull up the video
I sent you if you have it I'm gonna ask
them one more thing though um did you
guys give your XS you did you did did
you give your I okay what's your ick
this mainly like a lady that is always
negative and it's always moaning I'm a
very positive individual but you know
what it is for me it's all about
understanding each other and I could be
as happy as ever and be around someone
that is so not at peace with themsel and
they use another person to lean on for
comfort and this is why I always try and
tell people even like with men and women
everybody like work on yourself from the
core from inside to then develop an
understanding about yourself have a
relation with yourself to then put
yourself out there to know that you're
comfortable getting into a Rel
relationship because the negativity will
consume and they always say when you're
around somebody like you then become
like that and I can't deal with it so I
was like out with one lady one time and
just lagging talking about someone else
and negative about the ex and what he
did and I'm like babe you know
what I think I got to go home now you
know I'm tired I got a migraine you get
it so but yeah that's it for me though
that's that's it for me just the
negativity and the the non-p passion of
wanting more for yourself and positivity
so yeah um what do you think men should
get out of marriage um oh I like that
one out of marriage I think they should
get companionship um but why you can get
that out of a girlfriend why what a wife
why a wife um okay so for me I'm kind of
with her on the fact of like marriage is
kind of like a gray area because that's
kind of determined by the person because
some people consider like relationship
some people consider like a marriage as
just a legal document so I think it's
based on like kind of what you believe
or feel
about that sort of thing but I just feel
like in a serious relationship or like
um y'all are in a household together
married whatever that's what I'm kind of
referring to so I guess like the
difference of companionship in a
relationship versus a marriage is like
you're being a homemaker you know we're
making decisions together about children
and you think men should make decisions
with the wife um I think the that there
should be a conversation but I
definitely I think like I personally I
would like a man who can lead so yeah
like but I do want somebody who is not
just going to like cuz I'm not your
child so I don't want somebody who's
like making making decisions for me but
why would he consult you if he's going
to make the final decision anyway um
because maybe as your wife I could offer
you a different Insight different
perspective um you know I'm a grown
woman too so you know I have some wisdom
that what if he doesn't want your advice
he just he wants to make the decision is
that okay um yeah I would have to
respect that but you know from there
then you will understand that there
might be a conversation or communication
had to follow up it's just like any
other decision that's made okay so he
gets someone he can talk to about
decisions he gets companionship he gets
someone who's nurturing going to take
care of your kids um you know handle the
business at home Tri so then by that
logic the older women couldn't do the
kids thing like over 35 it's geriatric
pregnancy so should that be out for
women over 35 then should what be out
marriage um everybody don't want kids no
but I I said the like he would not get
marriage from or he would not likely get
children from a woman woman that's over
the age of 35 so she can't offer that in
a marriage yeah okay but I'm saying by
that logic then the older woman couldn't
offer that right um correct yeah okay so
what else does a guy get um
A vibe you know
like somebody to lay down with at night
you know that's that's just yours that
you're not sharing with anybody else on
the streets um yeah experience the whole
married
VI no A vibe like something that you're
not going to get from being out with
your boys at the poker game like that
kind of vibe like a different type of
feeling okay um what do you think a man
should out of
marriage um I'm not sure cuz I don't
think a man can really gain anything
from a
marriage oh very well
spotted I just I don't I don't yeah I
just I don't think yeah they they they
don't actually benefit because anything
they can get in a marriage they can get
without being married yeah honest answer
what do you think a man what do you
think a man can get out of marriage well
I think they get a loyal woman I think
they get a woman that is
no if they choose right they get a loyal
woman because you know our choices are
down to us and vice versa with men if a
man chooses the wrong woman then that's
what is the right woman wouldn't you say
a woman under the age of no I'm not
going to say age okay I'm not what is
the right woman because some no kid no
kids it depends it depends is the man is
is the man divorced or did he have a
previous where he had children as well
and now he's looking for something
different well but but the reason the
reason I'm saying is we know the body
count stats if a girl slept with two
people it's like 5050 on if she if it
will be a successful marriage if she
slept with four people it's like you
maybe have a 20% chance of having a
happy marriage so so my question is what
does the right woman look like with
these
numbers okay so the right woman is
someone who's peaceful who's got got
like who's there for her man when needed
and how do you measure that how do you
measure that yeah how do you measure it
you know cuz men need help emotionally
as well and I know a lot of men would
say they don't but I've been in
long-term relationships they do they
definitely do they definitely confined
in their woman and um need that um so
all I can say is when I was in long-term
relationship I would be running around
making sure that when he gets in from
work that the house is peaceful so um
that would look like running a bar for
him making sure his food was done when
he got in you know all those kind of
things okay um but then mentioning that
I wasn't married yeah but I was living
as if I was married I was playing that
role but that's the that's the question
is like what what can a guy get out of
marriage that he couldn't get from a
girlfriend cuz you can have a loyal
girlfriend yeah so when I was younger
and obviously would have had the
opportunity to get married um I didn't I
didn't really believe in the piece of
paper I believed in loyalty I believed
in you know I'm here and I'm not going
anywhere we you could do a church
marriage that's fine but still but I
didn't believe in I didn't believe I'm
not talking about you I'm not talking
about what I'm saying is it's hard to
speak sometimes without basing it on
yourself I think everyone's done that
here so far it's it's the easiest way to
speak on a subject that's like a female
thing no yeah it is it's it's more of a
no I'm saying it's much more of a it's
much more no no it's much more of a
female no because that was an individual
question well where the second question
is more General women tend to interpret
information more individually where men
will answer questions more like
logically typically yeah because we have
um this which is fine that's why we
compliment each other which is I'm not
saying it's a bad thing that's what I'm
just you're kind of arguing with me
about it that's I'm just saying they're
different um but my my question more is
like what does a guy get out of marriage
like what should he get out I think
those were good answers though the house
peaceful yeah well I think nothing then
because you know when the yeah cuz the
girlfriend's missing up the
game
right stop taking care
of I'm not I'm not sure that's the
conclusion I'm is the conclusion oh the
boys are getting dumped I don't could it
wouldn't it be to offer more value no
okay that was that no to offer more
value to the guys no no okay still me
all right
next no no no do you have anything else
you want to add um yeah I did have
something but I come back to it okay
okay thank you go ahead um leading on
from what you said as well peaceful home
yeah but they do get the contract the
promise ultimately with the marriage
which is different from the long-term
relationship where you're playing
housewife um I I would say say they get
as well the right okay so they get the
contract right it's the promise the
contract yeah because it comes with
punishment doesn't it so that's what
they get for the guy yeah yeah wait for
who who no no not always that's not fair
the contract uh the contract yeah no it
depends what's in the contract yeah
absolutely what's in the contract but
that's what it is it's a promise who
typically who typically gets child
support men or women um it depends on
what family you're growing up in but
most women probably get it right so then
so so couldn't we argue that women
actually get a reward for leaving no but
you can't nothing to money most women
that will bring up the children so the
women are having to bring them right but
that's like a catch bring them up that's
a catch 22 though because they're
punishing they're punishing traditional
man men if the man does what he's
supposed to do which is protect and
provide for the family they say then
they say oh gotcha now you don't get the
kids because you didn't spend enough
time with the kids but if he was at home
with the children he wouldn't he they
would say why don't you have a job yeah
you get penalized so you think that men
would prefer to bring the children up I
I think that I think that most men would
prefer to bring the kids up I think most
men I think most men would prefer to
have the authority on the decision
because men tend to be better people and
they actually don't hold the kids they
don't take away the kids out of spite
that's something women do single single
single single father homes turn out
significantly better than single mother
homes and and if you believe in like
patriarchy if you believe in men having
Authority in the household why would
they not have authority over their
children can I just say everyone said
they wanted the leader and stuff
wouldn't the father be a better person
to raise the kid if he's the leader yep
yeah but does he have the time to raise
him if he's the leader he still be the's
got he's got R money no but the the
point is he would he men will still give
the kid to the mother that's a feminine
like that's what women do they're the
ones that keep the kid away from the
dad where did they learn this where did
they start teaching where did they they
start doing that when did women start
doing that where did they learn this
from to when where do they learn to keep
the kids from the dad each other they
learn it from each other they tell each
other call someone up all you have to
say is he abused you and then you get
the kids and then you'll get money as
well didn't you say to call your friend
if you're having an argument isn't that
the same friend no I did not say call
your friend you have an argument
absolutely not you don't tell people
outside of your relationship about
arguments I said if you have something
that you're nagging about when I hear
nagging I think that that's something
insignificant so for example she gave
the example of dishes if it's something
like the dishes ultimately that's her
problem she's letting dishes annoy you
if they annoy you that much do it
yourself so you could go and call your
mom or tell your friend he didn't do the
dishes and it drove me nuts because
that's her issue an argument is an issue
within the relationship that shouldn't
go outside of the relationship yeah I I
would never ever tell anyone to take
issues that are within a relationship
outside of a relationship because that's
wrong on all levels this fuels it
more where are women learning I just
think when women get power we're bad
people yeah I don't know what it is
whenever
emotions yeah the scn of a woman yeah I
I think I mean I'm Catholic I think
there's a natural order in the world so
I I I think it's supposed to go God men
women children arguably government in
there too but but let's just stick to
the family unit God men women children I
think evil happens when you tell women
that they're equal to men and that's
typically like the last hundred years
what what policies have women passed
since they've gotten the most political
power they've passed policies that
oppress men but PE go ahead um what king
said earlier that they was there was an
equilibrium going on before where the
women would have to go out go get a
dinner and then build the home is that
what he said an equal yeah yeah I said
that but she was still under the
authority of her man even when she was
working alongside him so she got
everything no I'm not saying she has to
do everything the man was still
providing for the family but the woman
was working alongside him yeah now this
idea that women now to oh it was way
harder before Oh My Gosh have you
Googled like um have you heard of Amish
people anywh yeah Google like a day in
the life of the Amish and tell me if
most women could do that over a desk job
most women couldn't no I
couldn't no but that's like this idea
that women were just at home like
sitting doing nothing I'm like life was
hard for most of
History um like I I promise you your
your desk job is not harder than what
the women of times past
did physically yeah mentally well I
would say it's harder on women to be
away from the family right that's what
we got like work husbands you know it's
tough when you're around people all the
time you know to not mix that stuff
that's why they typically
do um okay so what about you men
marriage um the traditional Western
marriage yeah um they don't gain nothing
as she said previously they can get
everything without being married on a
contracts okay you don't need to sign a
contract you can get it all okay what
about you Sterling what should a guy get
out of marriage well I mean Cow Milking
chicken CP building and and maintenance
yeah what a guy can get there's only one
there's only really one thing that a guy
can actually get out of like a
traditional like legal government
marriage and that's immigration papers
yeah yeah doc that's what
I passport and another
passport he can that's the only
circumstance that is the best answer
actually also also I think
Alibi yes you getting personal now Bo
you look getting real personal now
actually I I'll add to that now you
mentioned that I'll add to that there's
one there is like Nuance depending on
how complex your business is you can put
things in your wife's name that you
couldn't put in a girlfriend's name
docents so there are some Bic Pap
forer for Pap paper if there's no
benefit in it if there's no benefit for
a man why are you seeking that
I I don't want to get legally married I
would get religiously married okay cuz
that's like for me that's
mind well government has nothing to do
with it I'm not I'm not signing any
paperwork done in a church with a priest
and and maybe a couple of family members
but it's it's under God it's not the
state has no godamn business in it like
that's that's why yeah
um because I would primarily choose to
and and well and he's marrying below 25
um non [__] no kids like there there's
some benefit you know but loads of
benefit for Rel he's not yeah he's not
getting the old ladies
right that's what back on
me um okay uh what okay what do you
think yeah I mean if we're thinking
actual physical what can you gain I
think that you've said everything really
um I think if it's not
a legal marriage and it's a say a
religious marriage um you know what what
you should gain if we say in an ideal
world where women aren't incentivized to
get divorced and take the kids in an
ideal world you should get what the vows
are someone who is undoubtedly going to
follow your lead doesn't need have
everything ran by them it's just going
to let you do whatever you want not do
whatever you want like you know if you
if you say I'm going to go out and and
do something that's going to get you
hurt you know know you would you would
try and say maybe don't do that but if
they do it at the end of the day like
it's someone who's going to stay with
you in sickness and in health till death
do us part till death do us part not
when I'm no longer happy and I decide
that I deserve something else at 55 or
whatever it may be it should be what the
vows are but that we don't live in an
Ideal World so yeah you don't really get
anything out of it apart from good good
answer you guys are
creative what about you what do you
think men should get out of marriage
well I mean what they should get is the
vows you said but what I believe that
they should get yeah is if I'm going to
marry you you should start building my
credit score or something
because especially if it's only just me
spending the money oh that's something
else actually um in rare cases I I think
you could gain um status cred so like
well you you mentioned about credit
scores so for example um you know when
you get married and you go to get a more
mortgage if you're with someone who say
the woman's got a better credit score
you know that way you guys might be able
to get house not benefiting or
guarant I mean that's the
case than if you get bu get daughter
yeah King King had some strong thoughts
on that relationship huh King my man
SM okay U what do you what do you think
if we're talking on the basis of the
terminology marriage I just believe
nothing uh I do agree with the vows and
I do agree with what um stering said so
and just respect and it should be the
original vows I want to clarify that
because yeah I have spoken to people I
know and asked them about the vow of uh
to to I think it's to submit and Obey
and almost everyone says that they chose
to have that taken out but it's the main
part of marriage and I think that's
disgusting
yeah so I guess the summary of all of
this is that marriage by the state is
designed for women correct definitely
1,00% you want to pull up the video king
do the song One
first so I was on Twitter I saw this
amazing song actually I covered it I
covered it on Pearl daily today um
wanted to get you guys'
take
um oh oh my
gosh my
bad my grandma paid me by the pound said
I should try to it
down went to meetings with my mom less I
ate the more they
applauded being hungry made me feel so
proud
still not full yet 10
years
[Music]
out didn't know to hate
myself till I learned it from someone
else didn't see what was wrong with me
just live in my
body did my best to lose the weight
hoping the her would go go away but damn
skinny feels just the
same always
[Music]
care um okay so Christine what' you
think of
that that's a lot is that a joke she's
joking right no no I think it's
serious
yeah so I didn't know I thought
potential heart disease feels the same
as not potential heart disease is that
what she's
saying I guess I don't know I I was
thinking that was such a good
opportunity like MoneyWise I was like
you can make like 200 said she tried
really I mean no doubt she can sing
right oh hair
lungs but you I tried so hard I mean if
you tried that hard you wouldn't look
like
that but she said like i s she said
being skinny and it's the same skinni
version of her now where's the skinny
version maybe she was they should have
showed
her yeah they show a comparison of both
what do you what do you think of the
song sterl that's an American accent
right yeah I'm pretty sure it sound like
it was an American the thing the thing
that people get so wrong with like
weight loss is like they think it's a
case of oh
like endless like you need like endless
discipline and you need to track every
calorie and all this kind of stuff it's
it's a lot it's a lot easier to lose
weight if you just have a bit of an
education about like hormones and how
they affect your body like you want it
look at this lady over here yeah looks
stunning for her age doesn't right the
way you the way you're eating is
producing a certain result in your body
right it's and and being American like I
guarantee that woman is eating food that
is empty it's empty there's nothing in
it she she she but she's starving
herself as well yeah she said
she tell you what my breakfast was that
woman what I was going to say was that
woman even though she like even when
she's not starving herself she's still
starving herself yeah cuz there's no
American food is the biggest pile of
trash it's all poison so everything
she's eaten even when she's trying to
eat yes that's why you got to grow your
own chickens and grow own cows and stuff
and she can probably do it because
American land is very cheap but like
even if she's trying to like eat healthy
and stuff it's going to be like low fat
it's going to be packed full of sugar
it's just there's so much deception
around like weight loss and how to do it
correctly it pisses me off honestly when
I see a woman like get that woman could
be gorgeous yeah she could be gorgeous
why isn't she gorgeous she's cuz she's
quite overweight so weight equates
equates to Beauty it doesn't make you
prettier that's it doesn't make you
prettier you you will get prettier when
you are at a healthy weight but I think
pretti is subjective
to your opinion not not to
men no it's not because who the men with
the most option date the same types of
chicks so it like it's like saying like
men that can't sleep with anyone else
will sleep with ugly overweight chicks
but the men with the most options don't
do it you look at Leonardo DiCaprio if
you look at the hottest most successful
men who those people are hot according
to whoever is looking at whoever this is
a question that has has pondered in
human history for as long as we can
remember and I actually did a video on
my channel go check it out guys is
beauty subjective or objective but the
point is there has to be an objective
standard for beauty otherwise how have
we decided what we like all over history
take it away from human beings right we
we can all agree that certain
architecture is more beautiful than
other architecture so there is an
objective standard there that we are
aware of at least most people are
somewhat aware of but I feel like people
feed themselves this that because people
have certain preferences to things that
they might find attractive in someone
that say someone else might that doesn't
take away from the fact that there is
such thing as objective Beauty they've
done multiple studies on this that find
for example people whose faces are more
symmetrical most people will agree that
those people are more attractive than
people who have less symmetrical faces
there's actually something called the
Golden Ratio which is a number that
appears in all of nature I'm talking
across cells to plants to human beings
to buildings I can't remember the the
number now for the life of me it's like
a really crazy number like 6.18
something something but when you see
this ratio reflected in a human being's
face not only that in their body as well
like how their body looks there is an
objective standard that generally most
people will find attractive that's not
to say like everything there is always
exceptions to the rule but there is an
objective Beauty standard that's not
something created by Society to make
people feel bad about themselves that's
just human nature in the same way that
peacocks they do that thing where they
display themselves in a certain way
that's because the other peacocks all
agree we like that and we can't forget
that we are animals too and we do have
something that we all like and can agree
is mostly
attractive okay yeah well
said most men just like
women if you're a wom they like it what
did you think of the
song hey she sounds
hurt she she seem sad yeah she she seem
sad well my question is I don't
understand why she took it as an insult
when like clearly you're going to have
more problem you're going to have have
more problems later on if you're heavier
and like you can either take it as an
insult and be the victim or you can take
it as your family trying to love and to
help you try to incentivize you to save
your own life yeah yeah what what do you
find um for people that want to lose
weight what do you think the best way to
do it is I think something more long LS
of like carniv maybe not necessarily
Carnival but like just like I personally
like the the structure of the paleo diet
because it's basically just and people
people misconstrue it as actually being
like full on Carnival but it's really
all it really is is like eat meat and
veg it ain't that complicated not
necessarily you can eat like you can you
can add potatoes and sweet potatoes or
is that K potatoes and sweet potatoes
are fine keto keto totally no C that's
that's an extreme but like if you if you
eat paleo you're basically eating like a
colorful array of vegetables good meat a
few carbs here and there it's it's but
it's all it's real food yeah it's
actually food you know it came out of
the ground you know didn't come out of a
factory it's really it's not that ain't
rocket science that's actually really
really simple to do yeah and you can and
if you just know like all you need is
like two or three good recipes MH you'll
get shredded but you know what before
all of that you need to have the right
mindset you you need to yeah you need
that one you need to be in that right
frame of mind to even get to that of
what you're say because all the food we
eat nowadays is so addictive
it's so it's designed to like get you
hooked and and if we're talking about
the the food that you said uh sorry you
said the family is essentially
incentivizing her to Bear herself you
know a lot of I can hear in my head a
lot of people saying Oh but you know
they could they could put it nicer and
you know we should we should Kate how
she feels this really bugs me this idea
that how you deliver a
message if you put it nicer it's going
to make a difference actually the truth
is is the biggest change comes from the
harshest delivery if you are told
something if someone really really
insults you that automatically in your
brain hopefully if you've got a healthy
mind and not a victim mindset that says
well I'm going to prove you wrong
whereas if I go you
know I've noticed that maybe you're
getting a bit bigger how do you feel
like that gives the person who's
receiving that message every excuse
Under the Sun to go well they're still
being nice so it can't be that bad
whereas if you're straight up
you are going to kill yourself you're
huge they're going to go [__] right and
get their act together it's more abrupt
yeah as harsh as it sounds but actually
I think harshness can be the kindest
policy because it just it gets it done
it's it's it's a sharp you know rip the
plaster off done I mean you would you
wouldn't mince words if if like a family
member of yours was shooting up heroin
all the time you're not going to like
sugar coat that out absolutely you're
going to kill yourself you need you need
to look it up well and I was thinking
I'm like I mean she's pretty big she
could have made a decent amount of money
she said $5 per pound that's like 50
bucks for 10 PBS I mean like like she's
what but that how much time is that
going to take that's a terrible return
on investment in terms of time spent no
but okay hear me out hear me out okay
she looks like like late 20s maybe okay
back then when you were a kid like
atone lot of money I'm like that was a
lot of money like I would have been
excited
if anything it was an opportunity for
you know you could get like cash
thinking like an entrepreneur I was I
was doing lemonade stance from a young
age but I think the biggest problem I
have with this weight issue thing is um
we live in a society where people have
kind of made it okay and I understand
that you can be um comfortable in your
body you can do all of that but the
problem with that is that if you look at
reality reality always tells the truth
you can't escape reality there's a
reason why you don't see so many
overweight old people there's a reason
for that that's because they die before
they get to that age most of most of the
old people you see walking around are
not overweight so if if you can't look
at reality and look at the truth that is
waiting ahead of you that just means
that you you're essentially saying that
um you don't care about your future you
don't because I just find it weird like
if I if I were to look out into the
world and see the F that men face
there's a reason why I don't do crime
because I can look out into the world
and see what happens to people that do
crime so it should be the same ideology
we should take when when people are
telling you oh it's okay to be this you
can actually look out in the world and
see the facts of reality because reality
always tell the truth so I just think
that people need to get off this
bandwagon of that narrative yeah that
narrative I think is very destructive to
people because reality doesn't agree
with that I mean the irony of calling it
like body positivity the irony there is
you're actually you actually don't
respect and love your your body at all
cuz you're not giving it what it really
needs and you're harming yourself you're
not you're harming yourself and not
actually giving it the nutritious food
and the exercise that it actually needs
to be its best and perform its best did
you know I applied to a body positive
organization I did a whole interview I
did I did yeah and I I I pitched in the
interview that like the best way to be
body positive um and it was like a
social media intern I'm like I'm great
social
media and so I know I pitched it to him
I said the best way to be potty positive
is to lose weight oh so so on the social
media I would really like to do some
like running campaigns like and I had
all these ideas they did not they um
yeah they they actually ended the
interview right there I was I was it's
part of an agenda though isn't it keep
us fat sick and easy to control the
government want us to believe positive
well and then they can just sell us more
stuff they can sell us the drug the
drugs money because when you're
overweight you're um actually at a
higher risk of all cause mortality so
it's not it's it's not a good outcome
yeah and you lost a bunch of weight
didn't you I did I would like to say I
actually was only that weight for a few
years and it's because I got depressed
and in a hole put on a bunch of weight
and then lost it yeah about six Stone
wow wow done well done congratulations
and that that was like two years of my
life the rest of my life have been shape
I grew up with a bodybuilder father that
was very strict and if I kind of went
out of the Realms of weight he would be
like army army he would call yeah Army I
mean yeah he would be saying no you
can't eat that you can't do that right
here's some chicken
breast I mean bad advice but back then
everyone was like chicken breast what is
there something wrong with chicken
breast yeah you don't want to eat
chicken breast where's the fat you need
the fat for your to support your
hormones you need the Fat Y oh Bingo oh
wow I didn't even knowen I didn't know
what chicken was but I thought there's
not bad but better choic you're going to
yeah if you're going to eat chicken
breast really you want anything with
skin on it oh okay so wings are good
they're in oh I love wings I love wings
but not but not American Wings covered
in sugar no that's what you're probably
referring to yeah wait so how did you
find carnivore how did I find it so I
actually started with keto first okay
and I was keto for about six months and
then I come across this doctor who I
then became to you know started working
for called Dr Shawn Baker and um he was
on Joe Rogan and I was listening to him
and he was saying yeah vegetables this
that and I was thinking this gu is
absolutely insane and um then but what
it did is it planted a seed and when I
was eating my asparagus CU all I was
eating is meat and veg because I was
keto there was no sugar there was no
junk there was nothing and um that did a
lot of good for my health but there was
still some little things my I wasn't
happy with my body composition m things
like that um and then I started thinking
oh hang on I just ate some asparagus and
now I'm bloated now I feel this like
feel a bit learic you know there's all
these downsides to eating the plants I
thought you know I'm going to try it
it's going to go wrong I'm going to try
it for two weeks so I tried it for two
weeks and I was like Wow Rush of energy
Clarity you know all benefits and not
only that first week I lost 77 second
week I lost 77 and then after that I
stopped weighing myself cuz I could
start seeing my abs I was feeling good
about myself and this was from the what
sorry what was this from the carnivore
diet okay okay it's not a starvation so
going back to that song majorly talented
woman um unfortunately she has been um
given some information that's wrong so
her parents wanted her to lose weight
and her grandparents and you know
whoever else in her family because they
wanted her to be healthy they were given
her really bad advice that advice does
leave you to being an overweight cuz
you're restricting yourself I don't
restrict myself I eat about 5,000
calories a day is that for breakfast add
12 sausages W and that's your add 10
eggs you know um you don't have to
restrict if you're eating the human
appropriate diet your body will do the
rest sugar withdrawal when you when you
went onto the keto diet initially did
you go through any kind of withdrawals I
didn't which is really funny because
before that I was in my hall and I was
addicted to coffee and cakes so I
haven't drunk coffee in about five years
I don't really drink alcohol
occasionally for the first three years
of the diet I didn't drink any alcohol
whatsoever um last couple of years every
now again I drink a bit of alcohol um
but yeah no uh some people get keto flu
and that's because they're not keeping
up with their electrolytes when you go
onto a diet that's low carb or zero carb
your body becomes really efficient at
dropping the water and with that you
drop electrolytes so you have to keep
replenishing those to keep those you
know and is that through just drinking
water salt salt salt so basically what I
do what I advise people that are
starting out new is to take magnesium
glycinate to um take salt I usually use
pink Himalayan salt um and it's a lot of
salt don't be scared of salt salt is
like as important to us as oxygen if you
if your salt if your electrolyte
balances out which is um you know your
sodium your potassium and your magnesium
you will have a heart attack right so
it's that important you know all this
scare mongering about salt is absolute
rubbish
and so what would you think of the song
so I think that yeah okay they had good
intentions because they wanted their
daughter granddaughter to get better
they wanted her to get healthy they gave
her some really bad advice and that bad
advice leaves you to constantly thinking
about food so if you're replenished if
you're if you're full of nutrients you
never think about food right it's like
you eat you you're full up you go you
don't have to keep thinking about I mean
when I go out with people that are on
high carb
diets you walk a little bit and they're
like maybe we need some
crisps maybe we need some sandwiches now
maybe we need and I'm like I've got my
10 eggs in my bag I eat them I'm good to
go I'm good for the day you know it's
it's it's it's
nothing it stops you from thinking about
food what are you eating a day steak
steak Yeah steak okay on my favorite
days I'll be eating a lot of steak so
sometimes I have two steaks for
breakfast okay and then what do you do
for lunch u 10 eggs well actually a lot
of the time I start with 10 eggs for
breakfast it depends what I fancy I
think um when you eat on your diet you
should be able to do it intuitively so
when I wake up sometimes I need more fat
so I put some butter on there or I get
their fattier types of meat I might have
a kilo of chicken wings for breakfast I
do that quite often um there's always
going to be steak in there sometimes I
make my own homemade burgers out of beef
mints always the high fat beef mins it
has to you have to cheese or you don't
do cheese right cheese sometimes okay
but cheese is addictive yeah cheese is
very addictive so um I can do it and I
can get away with it but I have too much
then I start getting dry skin and things
and I don't like dry skin so I just
think um when you're eating intuitively
and you can only eat intuitively when
you're eating human specific Foods
because if you're eating all that junk
crap you're actually addicted and your
body will send cravings for some
unnatural chemical Laden nonsense but
when you get rid of that you don't have
those Cravings anymore you actually eat
what your body needs like I wake up and
I think okay today I'm I need a bit of
fat so I'll have more fat or another day
I don't need so much fat today so I
won't have so much fat it's just very
individual to each day body yeah yeah
I'm in tune if I eat something at a
restaurant and then the next day I might
might wake up with like a little tiny
headache and I think oh something was on
that meat you know maybe they put it in
seed oils seed oils everyone should
avoid by the way do you eat meat so when
on the Carnival diet you eat pork you
eat lamb you eat I don't tend to eat too
much pork okay I enjoy pork cuz you said
you had sausages so I was like oh I
wonder if those were pork sausages
that's because that's because um I don't
like to waste and I could see that they
needed eating so I like sausages I don't
normally eat sausages they're not
normally part of my diet unless
something like that happens so I don't
like waste so but you you don't cut out
chicken or anything no I think it's for
the first three years I didn't eat any
chicken I ate just beef right um and
that will make you feel amazing that
will um and it give you really good skin
I found that when I changed the diet all
my health issues went every single one
of them my body composition got really
good had ABS you know it got abs sorry
um it's very easy to stay in shape when
you're eating what you meant to eat as a
human it's like you know when you go out
and you see all the animals they're
eating their species specific diet and
they are their body composition is
exactly as it's meant to be you know
it's really not rocket science if you
eat something that you're not meant to
eat as a human you know we're animals if
you eat something as an animal that
you're not meant to eat illness is there
over you know body composition that
we're never meant to reach is there you
know all these things and you know
saying um when I'm looking at a man if a
man's overweight I would I I wouldn't
even consider him because to me that's
laziness that's he's not disciplined
he's not looking out for his health you
know there's so many things that that
then flags for me so I could say that
was an ick as well there's way more
icks than I mentioned uh what did you
think of the
song um yeah I didn't I don't know see I
used to be big myself as well so I went
from size 16 18 to a size eight and I've
recently started to put the weight back
on
but um I don't
know wasn't the
best
iing it wasn't it wasn't appealing to me
personally I don't know it just seemed
like she she was just basically saying
she's still not happy she still lost
yeah she's tried for how long she's
still in the same position that she's
didn't that's cuz she's doing low fat
she's starving herself and she's
spending about food what if a guy made a
song about being
broke my mom told me to get a job it
would be really not very masculine would
it they've got another one what your
worst one what I was going to then I got
I was going to yeah come on oh
yeah just thought I'd say can I just say
what I thought about this song I just I
feel like it was a really mixed um
perception I didn't know what to take
from it in the beginning I was kind of
confused used then as it went in further
I was thinking all right maybe this is
to teach all the other little girls that
it's okay to be bigger maybe then as it
went further it says she was
unhappy then she was happy cuz she's in
front of the camer in bra and
niika I was very confused so I wouldn't
even be able to say whether I liked it
or not I did like the music side of it
but in terms of lyrically mix signals it
was mixed signals all over yeah but why
do women celebrate the wrong decisions
you know what I mean like okay a guy if
he's a drug dealer or criminal he
doesn't celebrate it
but they do they glamorize it a lot they
do yeah they do they you know what I'm
GNA take
that I forget about that I don't really
listen I don't listen I don't listen to
like it's like it's like rap music yeah
yeah I don't really listen to that but
yeah but they glamorize it but it's
still generally frowned upon by most men
that's the thing you're not going to see
men just come around especially men that
are doing things in life are not just
going to come and say yeah yeah we want
to be like that guy yeah that makes
sense yeah he's a drug dealer yeah
that's the life we should live or you
typically the men that push that on
young kids those are like you wouldn't
see a respon a responsible man even if
he does drugs as a side hustle you
wouldn't see him come out on TV and to
tell young kids this is what you should
do yeah but that's what I meant that
lady was very
confusing do you not think what did you
take from that eat more eat less well my
thing is like I just don't know you know
everyone's got struggles in life so like
that's that's her struggle fine but I
just don't know why do we celebrate the
wrong like it's clearly better to be in
shape it's clearly better to be healthy
that's clearly the better way to go why
do women celebrate the wrong thing but I
don't think it's just women like where
did this whole thing about just women
glorifying something because I think if
anything men do the same thing just
going back to the reference that you
just gave about drug dealers or whatever
that's the whole popular culture right
now everybody loves rap music everybody
is mimicking rappers talking about
things they don't know what the rappers
are talking about that's literally the
wave so I'm not going to agree with you
on the fact that only women glorify I
mean even this whole idea of threesom
and monogamy and whatever is glorified
it's like one of the reasons that people
don't want to be in traditional
relationships because it's in the music
it's on TV it's and who's who's who's
the decision makers Behind these things
being put out etc etc it's men women
women they do it for the audience women
women no no you're from Atlanta that's
like especially like no women make 80
because there's a lot of H earning women
in Atlanta no I understand yeah so so
women make 80% of consumer buying
decisions so the stuff you see in the
music the stuff you see on TV it's
catered to women I'm talking about the
the people that are signing off on
putting it out the people that are ackn
or accepting that this is being
glorified this is what we're going to
accept money in exchange for is men
generally older white men who have
nothing to do with whatever is being
even being put out but you just hit the
nail on the head it's men making the
smart decisions of how to make money how
do you make money well you pick the best
I'm sure that girl made money cuz we
just sat here and watched her video on
YouTube you just said about the general
culture and who's putting the things out
there I think you're hinting towards the
fact that the media and the music is all
owned by the same people and you just
mentioned the the typical well you know
that's all middle-aged white men fine
but the point is is that they must be
smart men because they're making bloody
money yeah but that wasn't the question
the question was why do women more so
glorify doing bad things versus men but
why do you think it is that th that
stuff sells more because women make up
95% of the consumer Market um I think
it's because we have a follower culture
so men see these other men getting money
looking flashy looking good taking care
of their bodies building their bodies
Etc whatever it is and they want to do
the same thing they want to flex they
want to look a certain way they want to
get a certain type of woman because of
other men but wait but do you see what
you just said there all of those are
good things minus the drug part minus
the drug part you just said they want to
get like they want to make money good
thing they want to be in shape good
thing they want to attract women good
thing but the women but the women that
are celebrated tend to be like I think
of who has gotten more of an audience
than Taylor Swift she's a 30-some year
old spinster who makes an album about
every single relationship that's gone
wrong those are the women we celebrate
you know and then I can think of like
Nicki Minaj right you know I I just saw
a video hear a woman saying nothing
positive or saying something good like
even if we're going to go back to the
fat conversation nii Minaj literally has
lyrics that says you a stupid ho you a
stupid ho you a stupid
ho
that's what no but but so okay why do we
have a [__] walk oh my God why do we the
same reason that we have everything else
I've seen something in London where it's
a bunch of grown men riding around
bicycles but naked no okay why
do why do why do we have a SL [__] walk
why do we have that so that women can
take their power back and feel like okay
they can accept it but that is just
because I'm saying this doesn't mean
that I'm necessarily
agreeing why would women want Toc
that um because we have things like roie
way going on where women are not in
control of their body so I'm going to
assume that you know is abortion
generally a good thing I don't know
that's depending on yourself your
situation okay okay why why do women
encourage it because it should be your
choice what you're going to do you just
made an issue of being in control of
your body right no I did not she asked
me why is there a SL no you said that
with regards to roie Wade that's an
issue that's going on right now where
women don't have control over their
bodies somebody making
that if if somebody can get pregnant
physically that I have no choice in
whether I have to carry this baby to
term and push it out and raise it that's
not control if somebody else has a
decision in if women if women human
being okay but I'm not giving you my
opinion on abortion at all the point is
is that you said it's about women having
control over their bodies do women not
have the option to say maybe I'm not
going to have sex with a man that I
don't want have children with some women
got get
raped not to say that exception
exception
because of okay well I'm not personally
going to have the abortion argument
because that was not my intention of
bringing up Ro weight I'm just giving
example of the [__] walk being a reason
why do but why do women fight so hard
for the wrong men have been in control
of every decision s the existence of
Eternity how how have men been in
control when men were the ones that
typically had to fight in Wars women did
not have to fight in
Wars I don't understand that question
okay in order to live in order to
survive as a spe species right you need
to protect Society women have never had
to do that never okay so how were men in
control the average man is in how is he
in control when they are the ones that
have to sacrifice their body their life
for the country because they decided
that we're the only people that's strong
enough who who decided men who the men
that decid what what what percent bi
wait guys guys guys guys what what what
no so I just think I'm just
so so I want to I want to I want to K
okay wait wait guys guys wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait so you're not you're
just not correct so when women wait wa
wait wait listen listen listen wait and
they they teach you history wrong it's
it's not correct if you actually read
historical Accounts at the time they
they rewrite history so one one thing
people think is they think that men are
the ones that started all these wars
when really they've taken wait wait you
you just did right but no you you did
cuz you said men are starting all of
these
warsing but you said that's the reason
they have to defend the country because
the men were starting these wars and I
said I said they they started the
decision that the only that men are
going to go to war okay okay but okay
okay wait wait so I'm saying in the last
500 years they took the men that were in
power and the women that were in power
women are more likely to wage war than
men women so so this wasn't just the
men's decision there were women rulers
and they were more likely understand
that completely but that was not the so
my my point my my point my point is in
all of history there was choices and
tradeoffs right and it wasn't most men
had very little power most people had
very little power so this idea that most
men somehow oppressed women it's just
not true women had much more privilege
in a lot of ways than men much more you
know even in all of in the last thousand
years if a woman woman committed a crime
she was not likely to get the same
punishment as a guy there was um there
there's been writings for like that are
200 years old of men complaining about
how unfair the court system is and how
women just get off in the and in the
West in in what in the West in the west
oh well in in the west
yes we're in the west right so we just
the world well the 500 years was
actually in the world which kind of
makes sense because I don't think women
understand violence the same way men
understand violence
but um yeah so this idea that like women
were oppressed and like men had all this
power most people did not have
power okay okay yeah I well I I don't
understand how that relates back to the
original question was which was women um
glorify wrongdoings more so than men but
I agree to disagree on your War segment
okay um but you don't see how women
glorify wrong doing doings when we have
a [__] walk
I mean that's one example there are so
many other things that both gend what
about the body positive walk or the body
positive movement and what's that's bad
according to whoever is deciding that
that's your opinion that's bad but would
you would you not agree that being more
likely to die is bad I well we all have
to die for one but I agree that you know
making decisions that are going to
shorten your life could be considered
bad if that's what you value everybody
has a range of things that they you
shouldn't celebrate it right um I think
you should celebrate whatever you want
to celebrate if you want to celebrate
feeling confident in how whatever state
you are in today that's your business
exactly and and men would say you
shouldn't celebrate whatever you want to
celebrate there are things that are
worth celebrating and there are things
that should never be celebrated that's
what most level-headed men would think
but most women have this idea of oh
egalitarian fairy tale land where
everything can be whatever it wants
where if you think something is good
then it should be good if you think
something is bad then should be bad no
they are objective truths about life
that's the fact okay another movement
that we celebrate is the trans movement
that's 80% women most women are a part
of that and support that and people that
do actually I've actually interviewed
people that do that surgery um they're
more likely to commit suicide a lot of
them have really bad complications after
and I I personally don't think that's
something that should be celebrated
maybe because women are naturally
nurturers that we're taking that
negative judgmental factor out of our
maybe because me personally just
speaking from my personal life
experience I'm not I don't I don't care
about what you do because the same way
you're having an opinion on something
that I do the fact that I'm overweight
the fact that I'm this I'm that maybe
you have something that's like you said
everybody has a flaw something that
they're dealing with so who are we to
judge and decide that just because
somebody is accepting that this is what
people are going to do with their lives
anyway and not you know casting another
sin of judgment onto them um so I I
don't disagree everybody's got struggles
right everyone's got problems I totally
agree but where I disagree is I don't
agree with celebrating it I don't agree
with celebrating I don't wait wait wait
I don't agree with celebrating the fact
that Taylor Swift has 10 failed
relationships I don't think that's
something we should yay Harrah I don't
think we should celebrate you know Nicki
Minaj saying youu ho youu ho youu a ho I
don't I don't think we should celebrate
cardi B having a song about [__] I don't
think we should celebrate being
overweight because I think those are all
negative things so that that's where I
disagree I don't disagree that
everybody's got problems everybody's got
struggles nobody's perfect obviously
everyone in your circle is going to have
problems and struggles you know I'm not
going to not be friends with someone
just because they're overweight right um
but where I disagree is the
celebrating that's where I disagree so
how do you feel about Pub culture
because you know know some people might
look at that as alcoholism or like even
just drinking culture in general oh I
I'm not a fan Dr smoke cigarettes I'm
not a big I'm not a big drinker I
wouldn't celebrate that
either I guess but when I walked in they
told me to get a drink so I'm just like
trying to understand the balance of like
you know it's the men and women thing
for me yeah everybody has a choice and
it's like okay we can sit here and we
can pay
other we offer you we make Cups of
Tea okay yeah I I don't I was like no I
don't make
anybody if that's the case if we're
going to put some type of like you're
bad because you sat here and you ate XYZ
and now you're 500 issue you're bad
because it's not an issue of you're bad
because you drink it's not an issue of
you're bad because you're overweight
you're bad no no no no no that's not it
it's this is bad for you it actually
comes from a nice place and you're
hearing it as judgment and you're saying
you know like who are we to judge each
other and I get where you're coming from
and you think that's coming from a nice
place but the truth is that's not nice
at all because if you have someone who
is self Haring and you give them the
razor how are you helping because they
want to do it in their mind it helps it
it relieves something it helps me the
same with anorexia if someone believes
they are huge but they are actually
seriously seriously anorexic if you
reaffirm that broken problem in their
mind and you go well if you're happy and
you give them la iives or diet pills how
are you helping them the truth is is
that without tolerance we can't discern
what's good and bad for society and that
actually comes from a place of love if
we can decide collectively it's not good
to be overweight so we don't celebrate
it it's not good and I agree pop culture
it's not good to celebrate drugs and
alcohol if we can make definitive
decisions on what's good and bad it's
not about your individual spirit being
good or bad no no no it's just telling
you you're making a decision that
ultimately in reality isn't going to be
good for you and it's like if you go
with the whole mentality of who are we
to judge each other how far does that go
because if we don't judge each other how
do we decide murderers are
bad no I agree I agree with you because
you said everyone can can you know it's
that egalitarian mindset that King was
referring to if you're if you're
deciding okay everyone can can do what
they want and you can celebrate what you
want to
celebrate some people are really messed
up and some people want to celebrate
murderers and what you think we should
just let them absolutely not we should
collectively decide as a society what is
good for us and what is bad for us
because without that we descend into
chaos it's not about you being bad it's
about you making a choice that's bad for
you every now on the
head yeah I agree but I also feel like
everybody is entitled to especially as
as far as there is a line because we
have laws so there is definitely a line
that you know has been established and
voted and agreed upon that this is what
everybody has collectively agreed that's
wrong if you're not hurting somebody if
you're drinking if you're smoking if
you're vaping if you're overeating
you're hurting yourself so what is it to
you to go and project your opinion on
someone else in this country you're then
going to put your um health issues onto
the NHS which is going to cost in tax
and other things everyone else has to
pay for like everyone has to pay for the
air pollution because everybody's
outside smoking cigarettes and vaping
everybody has to pay for a lot of not
comparable that's not that like okay you
think that vaping has the same effect on
the Health Care system and our taxes as
OB maybe not but I think that everything
you die too young you're going to upset
your family and your friends that's
going to cause a ripple effect what
about yeah what about your kid there's a
lot of things involved yeah so I'm not
arguing that being overweight is somehow
like an exception or it's okay I'm not
even arguing over the overweight Topic
at all I'm overing over the arguing over
the fact that it's not your say or your
decision or I'm say women are
celebrating things that are bad if
there's a group of people who want to
get together and celebrate whatever it
is then that's that's their right to do
so so so what what what I'm disagreeing
with is you said it doesn't affect
anyone ites and and that's where I'm
disagreeing I'm saying it does because
when when you have health issues the
everyone around you has to take care of
you and then the health system has to
pay for it so that that's where I'm
saying I disagree that it doesn't affect
anybody and the point of Freedom like I
also agree with people should be allowed
to exercise their freedoms to do
whatever they want like ultimately if if
people are telling you don't do this
don't do this and you still decide to do
it you know I'm not a tyrant I'm not
then going to absolutely put a gun to
your head until you do what I want you
to do because it's coming from a place
of love if you decide not to listen and
you kill yourself that is ultimately
your fault at the end of the day but the
point that Pearl was making was about
celebration and the thing that's what I
was talking about positiv body
positivity and the trans movement the
two uh examples that we just gave is
that when you celebrate something you
are encouraging it so without the
celebration because it's like people can
still do that right trans people can
still exist people can still be
overweight and be positive in themselves
but it's the point is the point is is
that it's projected and celebrated upon
society and we shouldn't be doing that
because it's not good for individuals
but if individuals decide that they want
to do that great I don't think anyone
should be forced to do anything in life
but if you celebrate it you encourage it
and what good does that do in
encouraging people you know we had a
woman on the front of Sports Illustrated
magazine who was
£300 we all know girls girls we've all
heard this narrative for years you know
it was in the '90s it was girls are
seeing women who are too skinny so girls
are then starving themselves okay well
now they're seeing women who are too fat
so now they're thinking oh well that's
okay and that's celebrated and the truth
is either way that's not good so I think
the point is is that people can do what
they want but as a society we should not
celebrate the things that are bad for
humankind that's the point and
ultimately if you then decide to go
against that um you know more power to
you but don't go out and project it onto
the rest of the world because it's not
good for people I don't think people
making a choice to celebrate something
that they feel strongly about that they
care about that they feel that they
relate to is influen ing other people I
think that if you have a weak mind or
you're easily influenced or you maybe
are not securing your own Foundation but
children we that's why I agree I agree
that's why our children shouldn't be on
Tik Tok or whatever they shouldn't be
having so much access to these things
because in the world people are going to
do what they going to want to do people
are going to kill people are going to do
other for example advertising children
walk around in the street somewhere like
New York City I've never been but I know
that you guys have huge Billboards right
what are they seeing on those Billboards
look at the latest Dove adverts right
things like that that's what I'm saying
so if we look on a societal level
children are a part of our society you
know we go to something like the trans
movement that is absolutely 100%
targeted towards children my point is we
shouldn't be celebrating things in our
society that are bad for the vulnerable
people within our society and that
includes children that includes people
who are weak-minded you know it should
be our human duty to look out for one
another and people putting stuff out
there I agree with you kids shouldn't be
on Tik Tok kids shouldn't be on
Instagram the point is they are so we
should be aware of that as competent
adults so to not expose children to
things that could encourage them to make
bad decisions in life can I just say ask
a question but being that a competent
adult that's raising these children the
family that that are so concerned about
her these let's say she's a traditional
family girl who was leading this family
as to what was put in this child's mouth
for her to then gain this weight and
then for them to now sit down
and say to this child you are now
overweight because now they've created
habits and addictions and so on so forth
because they see that this is not
healthy and they cuz they have the
knowledge because they know better they
are the competent adult they were
competent enough to provide the food
from birth to whatever said date that
she is now overweight so oh now we have
a problem and I'm going to tell you that
you're the problem and we this we need
to fix this problem but I created this
problem so we're going to come down and
sit with our leader whoever that may be
in that family and together as a family
and we're going to change the habits and
unlearn these bad behaviors that have
caused this child to now then be
overweight and we going to do it
together as a family or are we going to
just magnify this child who has now
learned this terrible Behavior which has
now caused possible health problems and
she feels bad or whatever it is negative
positive whatever it may be it started
at the foundation of her being a baby
because the baby did not put the
processed food on the table the baby did
not go and buy it the baby did not see
the billboard and say Mommy I want that
McDonald's and mommy said yes you can
have every time you say you want
McDonald's you can have it you have to
be able to make that executive decision
as a competent adult that chose to raise
a child and together as a collective
with whoever your village or your
support is and your leader and make that
then don't go and make the child feel
bad for your choices I agree with you
but she wasn't a child the problem with
that she started somewhere but the
problem with that
problem that is in the west we live in a
gynocentric society so even if you
notice women make most of the decisions
women are the ones that are raising
these kids most men and this is what I
noticed I'm I'm I'm African I came from
Nigeria I only came to this country
2019 back in my country even even though
it's changing but back in the day the
men were the leaders of this of the
family what they said goes but that that
even started changing a couple of like
years to go like but the reality is
women are the ones that make all the
decisions if a man tries to stand his
ground in the west he is literally shut
down he's literally kicked out of his
home he's literally seen as the enemy he
gets kicked out he
get men can't even enforce their
masculinity on their own families and
this is the point we saying of the whole
thing so then you should your partner
properly before about your partner it's
not about your part it's about the
society no matter how much you your
Society can an impact about what my
husband is I'll tell you why I'll tell
you why because there are many women who
were raised in Nigeria who were raised
with Traditional Values the moment they
stepped foot into this country went
haywire your wife or your husband the
reality is society creat the um toxic
environment for women to be able to run
rampant and do whatever they want okay
so how do you combat that do you now
then go when you're fighting a war do
you go to war without equipment I I mean
some men won't fight it that's point the
point is that that's the reason why men
are no longer getting married because
they see that they cannot have any sort
of um Authority in their homes that's
the reason why men run from from
commitment these days in the well it
used to take three months for a guy to
marry you now it takes three years on
average so it's like that's what men are
doing they're they're vetting harder but
honestly just doing this divorce
documentary I I would say there's no way
you could possibly no women switch up
switch up very quickly after they get
what they want um it's really I would
say it's a role of the dice um there's
high-risk women there's lowrisk women
but you're never going to know 100% what
do women get out of marriage um
protection and provisioning most men out
earn women so the average man still even
if it's more of a 5050 even the 50/50
relationships that I look at men still
work longer longer hours and they
contribute more financially um you also
get protection I mean there's some sort
of where are they
well I mean most most men um earn enough
for a wife and kids do they yeah I mean
it's just no but the problem is but the
problem is I'll tell you guys the
problem you you see you have jewelry you
have makeup on you have you have F you
you I know I know but but I'm saying
most women won't go down wait wait most
women won't go down in lifestyle for a
family so I'll give you an example my
friend my friend Rachel um she is a
homeschooled mom she had four kids and
what she did they never took vacation
she never had any of the latest fashion
trends she barely bought makeup she
homeschooled her children she lived on
like um they they had chickens they like
they she did all of that stuff most
women aren't willing to do that for a
family um and it the what she and what
she explained she's from um Midwest so
at Chicago or Mich Grand Rapid yeah I'm
I'm from Chicago and so what she what
she explained to me is kids really
aren't as expensive as people want to
believe it's just it's just like the
women want the vacations they want their
they won't do hand me downs with the
kids like they don't they don't want to
homeschool the kids they'd rather have a
career too and and the thing is when you
start breaking down men's income men's
income Peaks at about
55 um and and typically over the age of
30 men are making enough for um like to
have a family to have two to three kids
right but that doesn't mean that they
actually share or give or most most men
most men do most men so so if you at the
stats um there's only really about and
this is why I don't really get the there
there's like this group that's like
basically insinuating most guys are
losers the stats don't really back that
up the number one employer of men in the
US is truckers um and there's only like
15 Mone yeah they do there's only
there's only like 15% of men that that
are like the 20% I think it is um that
are the losers throughout their lifetime
um and the other thing is men are having
a harder and harder time getting jobs in
high-paying Industries because they are
discriminated against like I've talked
to recruiters um in like tech for
example and and there was even a um Tech
conference for women men were so
desperate to get like into that field
they infiltrated it they literally like
like pretend yeah they no but that but
that tells you how much like they're
being discriminated against for certain
jobs um so there's more traditional men
some wanted to be equal yeah there
somebody said it was a good idea yeah
well I would say there's there's
definitely a lack of masculinity like I
don't think most men were taught to be
like masculine but it's like who are we
most women weren't taught to be feminine
and and we'll always say we want a
leader but like what percent of women
know how to follow but those points you
said about the benefits of a woman being
married she could still get those if she
wasn't married right that's where I was
going works the the same way well but I
but but the difference final support but
the difference for but the difference
for no not the
because you can have more um basically
you have more legal rights as a woman in
marriage so quick question you meaning
in like when it becomes divorce yeah you
have more protections yeah you have more
protections for a woman inage a marriage
that who and and I would say men
typically actually stay so women
typically actually get the vows that are
promised where men do
not like men don't typically file for a
divorce and there reasons I I can't
remember them off the top of my head but
the reasons that men file for a divorce
are um like one is substance abuse like
they're typically more serious than the
reasons that women file for divorce in
general are these um so quick in terms
of like marriage and divorces that are
signed by a contract that you're going
to society has created a contract and in
a contract there's obviously rules that
you cannot break and if you choose to
then break this contract we go have
separate ways and somebody has to pay to
come so you pay to get into a contract
and now you have to pay to get out of
this contct are you talking about a prap
no sorry sorry say that again so
marriage in like when you go to the
court and you legally do these documents
it's a contract correct cuz you contract
say we together now we bind together
this is the contract so we paid to get
into a contract that was created by a
third party mhm and then we have to pay
this third party again when we decide
this contract no longer serves us right
makes sense so now so the third party
the third party has colle money from you
twice to get together right and so now
because something in this contract you
now decided to exercise this law this
contract that both both of us have
agreed that we're going to abide by this
whatever this in this contract but we
also have the choice to create our own
contracts as individuals we don't
necessarily have to go to the law and
sit down so I I agree with you but the
issue is in this country and in the US
when you have a child you're
automatically put into that system
regardless you know I've interviewed
divorce attorneys about this and you
know I I asked one of them if he was
afraid of marriage and he said no I'm
not afraid of marriage I could get an
ironclad prenup I'm not afraid of that
but what I am afraid of is having a
child because when you have a kid that
kid is not yours and you are always at
the mercy of her and her family if they
start getting in her ear her friends if
they start getting in her ear if she
starts watching the wrong stuff on Tik
Tok and he said every man thinks that
they can prevent it somehow but you just
never know for sure so again back to the
the decision makers right was it I don't
know cuz again it's a genuine question
was it a man or a woman that thought it
was a good idea to put this contract
together that benefits a woman cuz
that's what we saying it only benefits a
woman when the family cuz nobody wins
when the family fights so I'll tell you
I'll tell you why because I I had this
question like why why are these laws so
hard to change and so I started
interviewing men's rights activists who
have been trying to get them changed for
years and their overwhelming consensus
is that it we cannot get them changed
because the politicians can't get their
job they can't get elected unless they
cater to the female voters and the
female voters unfortunately for whatever
reason women are very selfish with our
voting power and and we we have voted
for policies that break down the family
and in the 1920s um you know we always
hear about the suffrages so the women
that like fought for women to get the
right to vote terorist but what they
yeah yeah yeah but what they don't know
is those those women yeah they were
actually they were known as terrorists
they planned assassinations they planned
bombings they were women who couldn't
get husbands and that's what they were
known as yeah they were known as that in
the community the anti-suffragists were
a movement that were against the
suffrages and they said no no no we
cannot let women have the right to vote
there will be increased spending and you
will see the breakdown of the family
unit and you will see an increase in
regulations
now it's it's quite yeah it's been
hundred years who passed the law no but
that that's my point women voted to get
the laws passed because those laws were
not passed when women did not have
voting power so you could argue that a
small percentage of men um were involved
in that decision but more women are
involved in voting than men are involved
in politics so it's a very small
percentage of men where women have
overwhelmingly voted to break down the
family so we saying that women had a say
in this contract that was put together
for them to benefit if the family and
when the family women am I saying women
had a say yeah and when the contract is
drawn is it we all sitting at his table
together is there a woman at this table
that says yes someone wrote that
contract well it it depends right so at
one it depends on the state you're in in
the US but when you have a child with a
woman you're automatically put like
you're put into the state system so then
basically what a woman can do is she can
be in a relationship in this country she
can go to a woman's shelter and the
overwhelming response that I've gotten
is that these women's domestic abuse
shelters that they have stories that
they tell you to say about your husband
so if he has say a Nigerian background
you say this story if he has a Muslim
background you say this story if he has
a British background you say this story
so they go there they get they get these
stories and then what they can do is
they they make one phone call and the
police can kick a guy out of his house
and and because they they accuse him of
abuse and what what women typically do
and you see women do this in
conversation is they change the
definition of things so if I say she's
fat they say oh no she's not fat she's
chubby they've done that legally right
so when you say oh she was abused it
used to just be a man hitting a woman so
women come in and they expand and they
change the definition so what they did
was they switched the definition of
abuse they added emotional abuse that's
very subjective they yeah they they
change the definition of rape it used to
be forced sex okay you know what that is
someone grabs you off the side of the
road right now it's sex without consent
subjective um and they Bas they added
the word sexual assault into the
language what does that mean most people
don't even like you know now they're
saying someone hits your butt that's
that's the same thing as an assault you
know I I don't know even in this country
you can get arrested for staring or I
how long um marage how long on the train
the posters on the train don't look at
any you if you someone looking at you
sexually report to the police wow wow
and so unfortunately when women get
power we're just not good with it I
don't know why we're like this but you
know and the women more agreeable women
or neotic it's all about personality
because it's nature isn't it we're not
meant to be in power we're meant to be
led if you do something that goes
against nature that's then when things
mess up yeah and so and that's what the
anti-suffragists like all the women of
the time were like there's more women
that were against women voting then were
for it yeah I just wanted to know I know
you didn't have a direct answer but it's
kind of like if you created something
who is the creative someone invented
this camera and now the camera is
faulty okay so I'll tell you the the
deciding vote for um giving women the
right to vote which by and large changed
the court system it it was a guy who
basically did it because his mom was an
anti-suffrage it that was like the
deciding vote so he was kind of like the
OG simp so they said he
a man he was still a man isn't he yeah
but here's the thing the reason why men
give women the right to vote is because
by and large men are good people and
they thought well women should have the
right to vote now women get the right to
vote but what do they do with it that's
so are you saying that prior to women
voting the contract of marriage was
completely different after women became
family family well I'm talking about the
contract of marriage because we saying
that the contract benefits woman cont
it's a it's a multi- to really
gynocentrism goes back a thousand years
so it like men being discriminated
against in court isn't
necessarily a new thing I think we just
have a natural men just have an innate
ability to want to protect women however
the culture was really different and the
family court yeah the culture yeah CU
women respond really quickly to social
shame yeah yeah so you know when when
something is shamed upon as a culture
that's why I say it's not good we
celebrate these things because when
things are celebrated women tend to do
it when they're shamed we tend to not
we're going to celebrate him when he
gets a divorce and he looks off his
exwife now and his kids we celebrating
him because he's doing the right thing
he is still providing he's not being
better he's not cutting her off she
should ultimately not want to take away
but again he might decide he wants that
24 year old now because she's 35 she's
giv him the kids and he's like oh I want
a bit of something different I again
different conversation about if a man
can be with one woman for the rest of
his life that's a different Rabbit Hole
so she might not agree to that so then
that might be a reason as to why she
decides that that's no longer for her
right but the problem is we don't
celebrate women being amicable after
divorce we do not we do not celebrate
and say we celebrate bit women we I I
would say we do celebrate bitter women
yeah I know we shouldn't but I I'll give
you an example like um anyone Carrie
Underwood fan anyone no one no you guys
don't listen to Country here but there
was a big there was a big yeah but and
there's other examples but one that
comes to my head is there was a top
country song about a woman keying a
guy's car after he cheated oh do you
know what I mean like a couple of them
in the pop culture too yeah yeah the one
one them do a
lot I might kill my ex that is literally
in the
charts I might kill my ex can you
imagine if that was a man singing that
song I might kill my ex not the best
idea and everyone's like ah it's funny
because she's just a woman and she's
crazy if a man made the same song in a
rap song in a rock song I don't care
what it is if a man said the same thing
the media would be going nuts but it is
absolutely glorified in our culture
there's another one as well um it's
Megan Trainer I I did an episode on this
so I I spent a long long time
researching the charts and how things
have changed over the years how music
and television what they show us right
even in soaps you never hear in soaps
anymore of you know Onie stenders no
one's been together for 30 years
someone's having it off with someone
everything's chaotic in music again
Megan Trainer there's this song and she
says
um she says I am your mother you listen
to me I don't want to hear none of that
man splaining and the whole song is
basically composed in such a way of this
gynocentric Society so you have this
queen kind of in a dictatorship figure
and it's basically the whole song is
just putting down men lots of women's
music that is in the charts if you read
the lyrics you would be absolutely
appalled and you would only be appalled
when you apply it to the men cuz that I
might kill my ex song um another one oh
she's sweet but a psycho can we imagine
if if we had a song about a dude where
he said oh he's a gentleman but he's
also a narcissistic abuser we celebrate
these things in women but if you heard
it as a man I I heard the uh the other
song in when I was selling photocopy is
before this job um I heard this song and
it was like I might kill my ex and it's
like a really like creepy song catchy
and it gets in people's heads and we
don't know what kind of subliminal
messaging that's doing to the
unconscious minds of people exactly yeah
back to again gend subjective and yeah
exactly but like basically there was a
small percentage of you know I would say
simp beta men that decided to give women
all of this power and then all of men
had to pay for it is are those the same
would you put them in the women of that
they call the Pik mes women and the simp
is that like mirror like the men version
of the Pik mes girls that they say they
oh she's a Pik me like she's going to
agree that she wants to be a
traditionalist and she just wants
because she just wants to agree when
when I when I think of simps I think of
a woman
right I just think it's like a woman in
a guy's body that's what I think of so
he disagrees to everything for women's
benefit no I think simps will tell you
you yeah they tell you what they want to
hear and then well but they call a pikme
anyone that like listens to her husband
they call it pikme they they kind of I
hear you okay the difference is women
should absolutely be pikm and men should
absolutely not be simps that's the
difference one one is bad for society
and one is actually good for
society not everybody wants to get
chos all right they can happily live
live
alone um okay what do you think of the
song Oh with the chubby girl um I
shouldn't say that should I don't want
to offend the ladies you know what um I
feel like she just lazy but the song
itself was a little bit it sound like
she just wanted to cry about life she
just sounds like the traditional person
that would just continuously moan all
the time like my mom didn't appreciate
the way I look she told me to do this
and I didn't I tried to do it and I
couldn't do it and all this kind of
stuff it just sounds lazy to me and what
everybody was talking about eating
certain things and that you don't really
have to do that you just have to wake up
in the morning walk down the stairs
instead of taking the
elevator walk to the gym instead of
driving there just simple stuff that you
could just do to lose weight without
even changing your diet not hard what do
you think I think her voice was amazing
as a singer I think she's incredible I
know her voice was good I was like the
song kind of slaps a little
bit terrible it's kind of like I don't
like the lyrics but it's kind of
fire was it I just think that voice was
good but she was in her mental space was
in a bad place um yeah so her delivery
was very up and down regarding what she
wants as to most so what she doesn't
want that's it really well thank you
guys all for coming um I I think we're
going to do final thoughts so um I'm
going to read the super chats really
quick um and then you guys can give you
know any final thoughts you have on what
we learned today or the show or anything
um okay guys um make sure you like the
video um that's the most important
metric that YouTube uses um also okay
Chris hoodie girl claims to be
traditional LOL boundless Guardian no no
okay I'll let
you know we are okay I'm boundless um
sorry BR sorry guys let's let's just
read through the Super Chat so we can
get through it quickly okay boundless
Guardian um help is only help if the
intent is positive if someone punches
you in the face with the intent to help
you learn to fight um there's a
difference than just hitting you in the
face to hurt you promoting Lifestyles
works the same ways intent matters
normally you're on point Pearl but men
of all Races and colors got the right to
vote via the 15th Amendment women didn't
get the right to vote until 1920 um so
previously enslaved men voted before
wives did that is a sad fact 93 top pie
I love my BBW but if there's a fire I'm
not carrying you if we
have if we have if we have kids who's
going to play with with them first dates
should be walking flights of stairs um
Chris this 40-year-old lady can't think
in general because she's only thinking
about her selfish wants women generally
think in a narcissistic way and will
always make things about themselves and
see can't see past their nose 90 free
topai women during a possible World War
II still have delusional standards so
many bombings on civilians almost
record-breaking second to Pearl reading
super chats um American viruses Freedom
women started getting
custom women started automatically
getting custody during the 70s with The
Tender Years loss women would
automatically get custody with men all
right women would automatically get
custody with men getting every other
weekend at most um while having to pay
25% income to child support enter black
drag Dragon um thought on age Gap dating
I'm 41 she's 21 she brought sex
femininity cooperation compliance and
peace women my age are bitter angry and
masculine as a man our purpose includes
provisioning and protection of families
American virus is freedom shared
experiences are what build a solid
relationship men want to show women
their first experiences in the world no
man wants to offer you the world only to
hear that you already did it with other
men this includes in being intimate Doug
MP the whale on the couch has no room to
trash a man sassy apocalypse your
cholesterol is too high to be running
your mouth what a bad representative for
for American people harpoon whales sorry
um Hardley tone peace to the goat
Sterling um enter black dragon black and
blue toxic masculinity huge red flag
enter black dragon wife equals woman and
feminine energy 100% in marriage um is
oh wait I uh I think that's yeah that's
the last wife okay let me refresh it
just make sure there's more
um okay okay that's all of them all
right final thoughts starting here go
around and then second row go ahead um I
just don't see it as a man versus woman
world and I think that both sides could
offer a little bit more grace to each
other we can offer Grace to everybody
each other I think a lot of women in
this room could offer for other women
some Grace in life okay um thank you for
having me um final thoughts um it's been
interesting to hear everybody's
differences I mean your age age range
for me still blows my mind 24 but yeah
um yeah drink water and mind your
business
see okay so my final thought is
something that I wanted to bring up
before about um you know you say women
shouldn't vote I don't actually vote
because I don't think the votes count I
think that they're all wings from the
same bird and they're all puppets so
whatever your vote goes to it's G to
just happen the way they want it to
happen it really doesn't matter so I
don't vote for that
reason yeah last election was stolen us
go
ahead mine is just enjoy your life and
be happy because it's not long I it
done nobody wins when the family fights
mhmh happy to have blown some Minds with
my age
Gap
uh yeah I agree with what you said you
know it's politicians they're all the
same people in different colored tires
really most of them anyway unless you
have someone who's brave enough to come
along that's anti-establishment there's
definitely not one of those in the UK so
uh
yeah um Peace at home is the most
important thing G from
today my final thoughts are just walk
with love be at peace and have tunnel
vision all right guys um make sure you
like the video on your way out let's get
this video to 2,000 likes because that's
the most important metric that YouTube
uses to push out these streams also guys
um uh we are put we were doing shows at
the audacity Network so the next um
month basically we're going to put on a
bunch of shows with different YouTubers
so if you want to see the shows that we
put on we have a lot of stuff planned
for you make sure you subscribe to the
audacity Network um this is going to
include some of the show panelists and
regulars that have been on for the past
year and a half coming back and putting
on their own shows if you want to see
that make sure you subscribe to the
channel also like the video on your way
out and um I I think that's all the
announcements for now oh and sign up to
our Google form to be a part of our
email list I'll talk to you guys next
time